m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok ce qu'il a encore droit parfois
passer bien des choses et dieu tout ce
temps ce n'est la liste est encore chaud
des ménages allaient attend place et les
rockets l'andouille avec ardeur au déjà
déficit paraissait madame y accepte est
là tu peux être un esprit
[Applaudissements]
cette petite dame du mai vous qu'on sait
qu'à moi vous vous appelez d'emilie
adélie à bien
asseyez-vous merci j nat est mon ami on
est à steam vous à céret pas non non
jamais devant les visites quoi donc vous
croyez que je suive des fois vous auriez
pu être sa mère je suis sa femme de
ménage
jean était bon c'est connu autrefois qui
on savait pas aux revues ont servi hier
alors elle m'a dit de venir la voir
alors suis venu c'est chic c'est versé
du pij pas un essai de noir et portant
haut et cette armoire à glace
c'est au cesi va rentrer dans sa poche
et vous c'est du du sahel machin
inattendue du fayet tout de même quand
on pense qu'à trois mois l'été arpète
350 par jour et les pourboires après la
vie j'en ai vu bien d'autres depuis que
je fais des ménages
il a donc trouvé un à viry un petit
jeune africain ces gens qui c'est c'est
joli ça de la cravate mais c'est pas
sérieux
alors c'est pour lui qu'il a payé les
moeurs mais c'est peu probable mais je
sais pas comment elle s'arrange
elle n'a pas d'autres amants face à lens
elle ira loin
elle est jolie bien fait rigoler et pis
quoi elle plaît or vous sur cette
gentille
on se croit mal je sais pas pourquoi je
réussis par rld et ont des fois vous qui
allez chez beaucoup de gens vous
connaîtriez pas un monsieur qui
chercheraient une petite femme pas cher
et bien élevé
je fais un peu de cuisine chez soigner
les rhumatismes et je joue du piano avec
un double enjeu penserait même en ville
quand j'ai réhabilité
c'était gentil d'être venu voir si ça
n'a fait tant de plaisir de te retrouver
tu vas bien depuis hier un lien mais si
toi dont même berne où vous pouvez
disposer voulais faire ma chambre j'ai
mon cabinet de toilette et vidéos de la
salle de vin bien madame convient donc
ta pièce et bassiste l'antichambre la
chambre à coucher un petit cours qui ces
cabinets de toilette le salon la salle
de bains et petit endroit six pièces et
qu'elle mobilier de salle payer daoui
figure toi j'ai fait un héritage à
méritait une tente à moi qui m'a laissé
de 1400 francs on mais j'ai un petit ami
aussi qu'ils m'aident un revers qui
s'appelle un chansonnier de quoi bâtir
qui fait des chansons petit les chante
dans les cours mais non tu es bête dans
les cabarets de montmartre de ce moment
signé au chat qui miaule il a 5e
bonnette sommes là quoi toi tu
comprendrais pas la faute du métier pas
ils gagnent beaucoup d'argent
bah oui me suffit je suis très heureuse
comme ça je suis contente pour toi bref
ça fait plaisir de voir quelqu'un qui
réussit surtout toi tu prends fier tu
reconnais tes amis dans la dèche
toujours dans la bibine l'ubs jeunes
mais c'est ta faute et paul gates
on dirait toujours que tu reçois une
averse est à oublier ton part à ce
niveau dallaire mouillé il n'y a pas de
ré sonne déjà tu es jolie qui doit
plaire je plais mais pas longtemps
mes amis me l'a tout de suite et encore
sans donner de l'argent mais vous
laurent réclamé secoue toi que diam's
compagnon la demande des sommes à tes
amis
j'ose peau qu'est ce que tu veux que je
demande à monsieur quand on reçoit dans
un garni avec une tactique boîte d'une
statuette qui n'a plus donné si j'avais
un appartement comme le tien aujourd'hui
dos tu veux c'est toi c'est pas pétrole
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que ces passants là tu sais il
est chalus match et il m'a entendu
parler il a voulu voir si j'étais avec
quelqu'un décalogue et comme il l à gré
qui se sait que ces manières août
crois-tu pour oser entrer dans un sas
entre ap allez recommencera est entre
autres au partant je vois que tu n'es
pas seul
non mais t'as rien de rien entre est
tout de même je te présente mes
meilleures amies à l'essieu d'un
meilleur ami mais je n'ai jamais vu la
sécu hier ton chat retrouvé tient
français autres ou alors monsieur comme
ça vous êtes jaloux moi tu comprends pas
que les normes soient jeunes à toi que
ça vous avance vous savez bien ce pas
que vous n'êtes pas avec ginette pour la
vie mais je vous remercie de me le
rappeler ses gaffes et ça fait toujours
plaisir à entendre ces choses là
évidemment je le sais bien qu avec
ginette ça durera pas toujours mais
pourquoi pas au toujours évidemment
c'est peut-être beaucoup mais ça peut
durer des années si ça dure des mois ce
sera bien beau mais je ne frappe pas je
sais bien qu'un jour tu trouveras mieux
que moi eh ben c'est parra puis voilà
tout à la seule chose que je demande
c'est de ne pas me faire de seine a pas
plus que je n'en ferais c'est par
essence cardio terre mais ça s'est
jamais vu il va s'agir à nous c'est
convenu ce jour-là on amènera se base
donc les oiseaux oui aux oiseaux est
unités rivales est de robert plutôt que
te dire des choses comme des mal élevés
hélas celui qui voudra plus important à
l'autre
ce serait dans une cage comme ça pas
besoin pas de respecter cela z oo le
l'oiseau ne t'inquiète pas mon petit ma
mère je te le donnerai pas encore
aujourd'hui mais j'espère bien je m'en
vais oui c'est ça a dit dont je ne
retiens pas mais tu peux revenir dans
une heure on déjeune rappeler 3 je
t'invite revers apportera une tarte et
gentille jacques c'est moi j'apporte red
epic 'les c'est que ça chez moi
descoings des pick up des machins
anglais ces petits oignons des
cornichons des piments trempé dans du
vinaigre
j'en ai toujours faut croquer la nuit
quand j'ai mal à l'estomac
[Musique]
bon alors à mêler à tout à l'heure enfin
monsieur dame
amusez vous bien
mais pourquoi tu l'invités les rase en
hausse et une si bonne fille c'est une
gourde et puis savent économie de rente
est jeune et ça lui fera plaisir elle
réussit porte à part bleus avec cet air
découragé et un nom comme ça amélie at
on idée de s'appeler avait ni amélie cc
c'est pas excitant dans les jeans est
sexy tripoli la traque du feu hier après
midi tu es sorti j'ai fait des courses à
tous et j'ai été suivi a encore par un
type d'emphase paris tout juste il a
essayé de me parler mais j'ai fait ma
tête de femme honnête
tiens comme ça où allawi s'est débiné à
bielle buffle sais je suis sûr qu'il est
à la fête en train de regarder ce qui se
passe chez nous robert qu'est ce que je
te disais il est là espèces le bar est
moitié jour je vais finir par manquer
chez michalon tu as tu sais bien que je
n'aime que toi c'est bien vrai ça
chaloupe s'en va et vient onctueux
robert oui tu devrais acheter la tarte
quoi pour le déjeuner avec amélie il y
aura toujours une tour bon j'y vais on a
tout à l'heure il est parti ouais bon
bah je vais finir ménage parce que
j'étais les autres pièces dia il vous
mettrais drapeau vert ici j'ai des
vanités
robert tu n'as qu'une famille avant il
est gentil robert non oui ça pour être
gentil les gentils moi c'est pas mon
genre
lui dit face à lui porter un coup non
plaqué blagué n'empêche qu'il est trop
jeune pour faire un amant un gigolo oui
mais un amant un sérieux pas cédric de
davos est dit on n'est pas concerné
c'est pas pour et essais pour travailler
c'est pour gagner de l'argent pour
augmenter sa femme de ménage
tu dis aux reproches maire bruno bias ne
faut pas qu'un homme aves par un flux
net nous fait que vous pouvez laver
qu'un petit criquet comme sétoise au
delà tout à chacun sait que vous ne
pouvez pas grand chose
une femme comme vous mais mérite un
vieux et vous l'aurez
c'est moi qui vous le dis maintien bah
oui voyez vous des vieilles femmes ou
jeunes gens et les jeunes femmes au
vieux monsieur
ça c'est des unions bien assortis
clermont a sonné qui ça peut bien mais
c'est pas déjà amélie bon ben je vais
aller voir
c'est un monsieur compte stanislas de la
ferronnière arrive pour un dans le coin
affiches on peut ne pas le recevoir
nananan celui là c'est pas parce que
vous croyez non j'ai été qu'il viendrait
plutôt vous proposer des reconnaissances
du mont-de-piété il est un cadre manière
oui et puis de toute manière non non on
sent qu'ils la gagnent blesse et
humaines de l'éducation dont tu as fait
l'avenir on verra bien
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien devant mademoiselle gillett
marson que j'ai l'honneur de me
présenter et monsieur le comte
mais là je vais vous dire tout de suite
et si pour la bagatelle avaya rien faire
parce que j'ai un petit ami que je peux
y faire des miss tout non mademoiselle
non ce n'est pas de la bagatelle qu'il
s'agit avant de vous exposer l'objet de
ma visite autorisée mois à m'asseoir car
je monte plusieurs étages dans ma
journée et mais force est là ce ne sont
pas infinies essayez vous officiel
commente je vous remercie
mademoiselle la famille de la
ferronnière donc je suis le dernier
représentant a connu des jours de faste
de quoi de faste de splendeur s'il vous
plaît mais notre situation a peu à peu
des crues et j'ai dû moi hyacinthe louis
bénédicte stanislas compte de la
ferronnière me mettre à travailler comme
un vilain pour gagner mais il me fallait
adopter un métier qui ne me fie pas
déroger je les trouve
je me suis institué professeur de belle
manière pour 2000 monde n ascendante
ascendant oui qui monte ascendante comme
ascenseur
tout juste non j'ai remarqué depuis
longtemps que les hasards de la vie
modifiait brusquement la situation d'une
petite femme et que du jour au lendemain
elle devenait de petites grues est dans
la pure et courtisanes de marque d'un
ami à 600 francs par mois elle passait
tout d'un coup à un amant à cent mille
francs par an a nouvelle situation il
faut une nouvelle éducation et la petite
brute est à 500 au front de peu par les
marchés et les livres comme
l'horizontale à sao il est bien
mademoiselle quand une femme monde
je suis là moi pour la guider au seuil
de sa nouvelle vie jean de charge de la
dégrossir de l'éduquer et d'une créature
mal embouché je fais il eu personne
raffinés tiens vedette raffineurs de
dribbles
oui c'était si vous voulez aider pour ça
que vous êtes monté cause et c'est pour
ça que je suis monté vite parlé et quand
vous avez eu mon adresse un arrangement
avec poupée conseillère du quartier
moyennant rétribution elle m'indique que
les petites femmes qui viennent de
s'installer jeu ma forme et quand je les
crois comme vous susceptible d'arriver
si ces petits pourquoi vous me dites que
je suis susceptible en fac donc je veux
dire capables digne d' arriver vers vous
croyez que moi j'avais trois des
abandons très web après londres
j'en suis sûr nous l'avons remercié les
flaps à voir mais puisque vous d'être si
sûr que ça que je réussis à hebinger pas
un goût alors n'attendons trois lycées
je vous arrête
vous n'avez pas besoin de moi pour
arriver vous en avez besoin pour vous
maintenir oui quand vous aurez trouvé la
banque chic riche et généreux croyez
vous que vous serez garder non bâloise a
évidemment vous êtes jolie comme un
petit espiègle qui vivent eux jeunes
tout cela est très bien dans l'activité
c'était insuffisant pour la galerie vous
n'avez pas la lui on va regarder vous
vous ne marchez pas vous senti vous de
vous asseyez bouton vous ne riez pas
vous vous tentez de dca langage
c'est flattot vous êtes monté cause et
ne marchait renfort jamais un homme chic
n'osera vous sortir vous emmener dîner
dans un grand restaurant vous présenter
à ses amis il nous irait de vous
or sachez le on prend une femme par
amour on la garde par amour propre
croyez moi avec les façons que vous avez
vous ne garderez par un homme plus de
huit jours
j'ai en gardant le fils y voir un petit
en acidifiant 1 300 francs par mois
comment savez-vous je vois c'est la bc
du mexique et bien non cheikh jarrah n'y
a rien à faire avec moi mon petit
insignifiant mais si il vous suffit
vraiment c'est admirable alors si un
jour ou demain peut-être la fortune
vient à monter vos quatre étages et à
frapper à votre porte
je n'ouvrirai pas la forte houle
jugement ne suis pas une femme d'argent
et vous n'avez pas le droit de parler
ainsi
mais non alors vous vous imaginez que
vous autre courtisane vous êtes libre de
vous d'aller à qui bon vous semble au
gré de vos qu'à paris c'est de me
confronter vie détrompez vous nous avez
un rôle à jouer dans la société
vous avez à remplir une fonction sociale
c'est pour vous que l'homme par son
travail accumule les richesses et c'est
vous qui pourra voter le luxe encourager
le commerce intensifier l'industrie est
galvanisé l'agriculture et c'est vous
qui prenons toutes ces fortunes dans vos
petites mains des répandez autour de
vous en man bienfaisante
vous êtes non seulement les
dispensatrice du plaisir mais vous êtes
aussi les distributrices du bonheur vrai
alors que je me doutais que ça vraiment
vous croyez que je ne crois pas je suis
sûr que vous êtes une des élues et le
jour où le destin bien à vous dire
ginette masson tondeur est venu lève cet
homme et marche
dès ce jour là vous obéirez vous ne
pouvez pas vous n'oserez pas vous
dérapez votre mission car ce seraient
désertés et à ce moment là vous aurez
besoin d'un professeur de belle manière
moyennant un forfait de 500 francs je me
charge en 30 leçons de vous apprendre à
parler à écrire à vous lever à vous
asseoir à vous tenir à table a ordonné
un menu et à soutenir une conversation
sur n'importe quel sujet m'avait alors
vous massez y est parfait mais ça
m'étonne que ça peut bien être
peut-être le destin mais ce sont des
fleurs vient d'apporter pour vous
pourquoi mediapart qui je sais pas on
attaque aux missionnaires qui vient de
monter merci valmer nos forêts je me
demandais qui sait qu'un feu venait
d'envoyer ses dents commerçants tout cas
moins fameux g2 vide envoyée ce bouquet
c'est beau c'est gros et plantureux
ça n'est pas feint pas l'espèce rare pas
de choix
ce n'est ni d'un artiste dit
d'indélicats annoncée d'un commerçant ou
d'un industriel où les hommes d'un
certain âge entre 45 et 50 ans jeune il
serait dit lui-même plus vieux il aurait
envoyé un bijou et homme que vous
mènerez par le bout du nez et dont vous
fait ce que vous voudrez car c'est un
débutant et un inexpérimenté
voyez ce papier peint cette grosse
ficelle un expert se serait adressé à
une fleuriste plus raffinés enfin 50 ans
commerçants débutants c'est la belle
pour tous mes compliments au boom abruti
c'est tout ça fait des avances ont fait
des blagues ya une bien dans le bouquet
est de voir la bombe 31 rue fontaine et
celle type dans vase commerçants pas ce
maudit en gros c'était durant qui sont
la rage et les sept auteurs mais qu'est
ce que je voudrais le vieil ingénue
l'heure a sonné moiselle je vous laisse
ma carte dont 15 on vous prévient il va
éroder le petit jeu sera rompu d'ici là
c'est moi qui vous le dis au château
naquit dans la porte et dès qu'ils
rentrent mais qu'est ce qui va bien
pourtant plus et tous les faits dont je
la nomme ici qu'est ce qu'on fait là
vous vous trompez d'autres que je ne
suis pas un drame vraiment je suis prof
et ça je suis venu offrir mes services à
bas 3 mj d'être mince
un professeur de quoi de belle manière
contre stanislas de la ferronnière c'est
ce que vous fichez moi j ai pas que
faire de belle manière vous vous trompez
monsieur elle a besoin de mes conseils
beaucoup de gens en auraient besoin
qu'ils ont fait pour moi vous dit ça je
vous préviens je n'ai pas l'intention
delphi peu plus pour isola mon éducation
ne m'a pas de renseigner à m'entretenir
sur ce ton et j'ai l'honneur de
multiples et marinés et bien c'est ça
allez vous à
vous avez dû 15 jours oui ces 8es encore
mademoiselle tout veysonnaz
assez du jeu il suffit que je m'absente
un quart d'heure pour qu'un homme
s'introduit ici qu'est ce que c'est que
ce type là régalant si ses membres qui
révèrent c'est pas pour dire mais qu'est
ce que tu fais est rasant oui mais bon
la fin j'ai promis que je ne fais pas de
scène je ne t'en fais quoi ce bouquin
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bouquet qui
l'a porté ici d'abord ça va recommencer
c'est le dieu odin que j'ai trouvé ici
des spams et non c'est pas lui dis ça
alors le pid enfin alors tu m'as vous en
pleine figure que le type d'en face
c'est ton amant mais non mais non me
fallait pas moins à même ses
fondamentaux
c'est dégoûtant on peut y aller comme
toi ya une éthique femmes ont passé un
ferrer je vais lui en coller mois des
petites femmes a par exemple il a acheté
une énorme lorgnette pour mieux voir ce
qui se passe ici
as tu veux voir mon vieux et vient
regard ou sur le point de quitter bernie
va chercher non chercher nos tu sais mon
petit robert je commence à la voir à
tête des façons c'était vraiment pas la
peine que je refuse pour toi des
occasions de chérir nouveau jury
parfaitement
j'ai raté pour toi des occasions uniques
et des hommes très riches et ses pieds
je ne savais pas mais neuf c'est là
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça fait mal
c'est une maladie
et non ça veut dire qu'ils aiment
l'argent moi il m'a pas regardée 1,6 g
mais l'argent est ce que je fais a
racheté avec toi pendant six mois
bah non d'ailleurs si je le tort de ne
pas ouvrir la fortune qui montaient les
quatre étages c'est que j'ai manqué à ma
fonction
une fonction sociale quoi parfaitement
c'est pour la peine de me regarder avec
des yeux de chat qui fait lors du son
c'est un devoir que nous remplissons nos
autre courtisane et sans nous la société
north mènerait pas large
nous sommes les distributrices du
bonheur et nous répondons autour de nous
la panne bienfaisance qui est ce qui t'a
four et ses idées dans la tête c'est toi
l'escogriffe de tout à l'heure tu me
crois pas capable de les trouver tout
seul toi tu les as seulement pas compris
ce que je comprends c'est que quand la
société une racine qu'elle a besoin de
moi tu n'auras pas le droit de me barrer
la route aux anges autant pris ma petite
ginette acea
si tu veux jouer les penseuse flûte moi
je projetais mieux d'après ce que tu dis
je jouais pense moi d'abord ventirad est
rejeté prierai de ne plus me parler sur
ce ton tu n'as plus devant toi une
petite grue est et dans la tuerie mais
une femme consciente
safar marché sur les rites attend série
tales tu mens bête tu mens bête tu mens
bay matt makassed m'agace m'agace si
j'ai un conseil à donner mon petit
robert c'est d'aller faire un tour parce
que si tu resté cinq minutes de plus je
jeu puis créé la crise de nerfs c'est ça
je m'en vais j'aime mieux ça mais vrai
ça va être drôle ici mac nord
par exemple payne ont pu entrer oui
eh bien en v'là in the scene vous
écoutez dont aucun nom j'attendais pour
mettre le couvert 1
croyez vous avez vous jamais rien
entendu de pareil pour ça oui et des
pires
eh bien vous pensé quand on fait des
ménages quels risques hommes et des
femmes
qu'est-ce qu'on peut l'entendre dans une
place ou j'appelle jamais vu un qui en
acheter une par la fenêtre
vous parlez d'une ça pousse 5 j'ai reçue
est aussi un sur première tiens ça m'a
peut-être amélie allait lui ouvrir mon
va lui raconter d'histoires et devant
les deux bavard c'est un monsieur bien
commenté ramon c'est quelqu'un de bien
de ce que bien c'est celui qui a envoyé
des fleurs edouard labeaume est bien
fait leur entrée
il tombe bien celui-là atteint elle
ressent pas aux yeux
ben moi je leur sers où la bombe et toi
c'est vous le monsieur d'en face eh ben
vous pouvez vous vantez d'état je rigole
alors monsieur m'a dégoûté au farm veut
se leur faire voir des selles
car pour toi même tu es tranquillement
les mains dans les poches avec un air
trop à l'heure comme si qu'on allait lui
tomber dans les bras
l'oit dans mon cher vous détromper
d'adressent 1 alors je vous ai assez vu
ramasser vos décaniller mais qu'est ce
qu'il ya il avait l'air tout en compote
ça vous fait tant des sexes à ce que je
vous raconte bien faut pas vous frapper
mon vieux il ya d'autres femmes à marier
et n'a pas d'autres y'a quoi je vous
aime je vous veux vraiment caillou mais
je veux un bon call of leon
mais n'ayez pas peur n'appelez pas mal
non je vous respecterez quoique j'ai une
envie folle de vous saisir dans mes bras
et de couvrir votre corps délicieux des
brûlots à cette façon de vous sautez sur
le lard
kim a fait alors vous en avez un
tempérament ben oui pendant 45 ans je ne
m'en doutais pas et puis la semaine
dernière en regardant par la fenêtre de
mon bureau je vous ai vu vous sortiez de
votre bain vous n'aviez pas fermer vos
rideaux l'électricité est allumée au
spectacle donné c'est grave et là je ne
l'oublierai jamais alors j'ai acheté une
lorgnette et tous les jours je passe des
heures à ma fenêtre
j'attends le bain alors tout à l'heure
j'ai assisté à votre scène j'ai suivi la
chute de mon bouquet j'ai vu votre
petite amie sortir de la maison avec des
gestes de furieux alors j'ai compris que
c'était le moment je suis monté mais
voici qu'un package étupes ce que vous
êtes inflammable avait alors je n'avais
encore jamais vu ça
enfin je vous en veux pas monsieur
labeaume et je suis flatté d'inspirer
des pas son pareil
mais pour ce qui est de la chance je la
regrette y'a pas plan bon pourquoi
non mais vous m'avez pas regarder le
prenez vous pour le marie couche toi là
ah non non mademoiselle non vous ne
m'avez pas compris mademoiselle non mais
pensez vous que quelques instants
suffirait à apaiser la soif qui me brûle
mais c'est mon existence entière que je
vous offre 20 ans des cadres je veux
passer ma vie avec vous que voudriez
vous installer ici ici ici mais jamais
comme escales par et odile digne de vous
oh non non je vous installerez dans un
délicieux appartement un déménagement à
l'arrivée nager quoi des meubles en pin
oh non je ne choisirais un mobilier
exquis digne de votre grâce à donner
tenez je vous vois très bien dans de
louis 15 moderne avec avec électricité
téléphone ascenseur à sancerre et
comment tu disais oh déjà ascendant
cependant rien bon je me demande si j'ai
droit de fermer ma porte est bien fermée
pour ne pas comprendre ça c'est des
idées à moi enfin vous acceptez attendez
vous savez si avec moi je vous dirai non
il ya le devoir le devoir mis six mois à
écrire mes réflexions mais c'est mon ami
mais je ne peux pas attendre moi et mon
existence est devenu impossible
les affaires périclitent je fais des
erreurs mais compte et purger j'ai des
distractions et leur déplorable de
l'éclair
au lieu de commander 40 kg tzu tâche
j'en ai commandé 40 tonnes
mais son jeu je suis pas tout seul mois
pas tout ça mais bon j'ai un associé à
ce n'est la maison racine à la bombe
c'est lui qui a fourni les faux c'est
lui qui paie c'est moi qui travaille il
est furieux incident il dit que je mène
la maison à la ruine tout simplement
voix c'est ça qui m'est égal à oui oui
oui mais pas à lui ni à moi dans ma
façon j'ai mademoiselle que si la maison
s'arrêtait ça ferait trois ingénieurs
ont commis deux caissiers un comptable
84 ou vide et 127 ouvrière en tout 228
personnes sur le pavé et la maison
s'arrêtera si vous repoussez d'un 126
personnes en moyenne
alors aujourd'hui racines et m'a dit bon
vieux en voilà assez mais toi avec cette
petite est ce soit fini là ça coûtera ce
que cette coûtera mais la maison sera
sauvé nous sont tranquilles non mais
c'est qui connaît les femmes racines et
c'est lui qui m'a conseillé de vous
envoyer un bouquet il me présentait
ensuite
et là il il attend la réponse au café du
coin
voilà alors vous dit tout et
mademoiselle il faut que ce soit oui
mais 228 personnes associées s'il compte
qu avait raison nous sommes les
distributrices du bonheur où ma réponse
messieurs la bombe c'est oui au repos
enfin je vais être enfin je veux voir
une maîtresse est passé bassinet qui va
être content je cours le rassurer puis
je reviens vous chercher avec une
voiture de cercle et nous allons
déjeuner d'abord puis ensuite rue
d'anjou retire l'appartement que m'a
indiqué racing et puis nous repartons
chercher un mobilier louis 15 moderne
toile
on a sonné ouais c'est pas votre ami non
non c'est pas lui la lépi dont c'est une
petite amie à moi qu'il ya des jeunes et
j'ai voulu la présenter
voilà avec mes piques à hawija véhicules
étaient présentes à monsieur dans la bo
mon nouvel ami
ouais on a eu des mots avec robert il
m'a fait une scène terrible je le quitte
messieurs la bonde m'installe dans un
nouvel appartement voilà messieurs
ben moi c'est de vous payer un homme au
comble du bonheur dit monsieur oui vous
n'avez pas un ami
c'est ainsi si j'en ai plusieurs
pourquoi des fois goûtera me cherche une
petite année gentille pas cher et bien
élevé pensez avoir acheté au taux de oui
ça fait un peu de cuisine et soigner les
rhumatismes drap bleu dont l'origine est
pour voir ginette me permettez vous de
vous embrasser oui
oh que c'est doux mais que seydou est
passé à sida qui va être content
en voilà une histoire crois tu toujours
bien pas alors tu vas être entretenue
faut croire et doit retrouver un bel
appartement à les biens meubles louis
qu'un débat en voilà une histoire
il est bien tu sais il s'arme monsieur
lacombe un salon pour être bien il
pourrait bien alors pourquoi que tu vas
avec lui puisque tu as toujours dit que
tu prendras qu'un ami dit plairait pas
ce qu'est un type qui est venu me voir
et qui m'a prédit mon avenir
s'amenant bull il m'a dit que j'avais
une fonction dans l'amérique est ce que
tu dirais que je te donnais mon
appartement mais mauvais tout la joyeuse
et va dîner tu blagues non tu me donnes
tout ça choix et l'armoire à glace aussi
oui jamais battu membres à spa belgique
possède pas non je suis et ben en voilà
une histoire bidon
maintenant avec ça tu réussiras pour sûr
ou alors faudrait que je sois bien
gourde téléport pas tant qu'on croit et
on la petite amélie tu vas me rendre un
petit service maintenant tu vas
descendre du toit la petite marchande
watteau tu connais oui de m'acheter une
petite cage avec un canari ah oui
pour robert et oui pauvre robert enfin
ils le font un le destin mater j'écoute
ma manie à merveille au final de mettre
le coup si vous vouliez d'ailleurs
maintenant ça n'a plus d'importance je
m'en vais passer moi mon sac de voyage
ah bon vous partez ouais et pour
toujours j'ai trouvé un nouvel
aux saluts bouquet ouais moi c'est pas
mon âge je voulais tu fais toujours dit
avec réussiriez pense à ça c'est une aja
robert j'entends là qu'il en apporte
élus qui rentrent et ce billet vous
c'est moi c'est moi qui c'est moi qui
celui de dire que ça ne peut plus durer
en outre j'ai réfléchi et j'en ai assez
depuis un certain temps on n'arrête pas
de se disputer alors ça devient très
désagréable pour nous deux
alors voilà pas de cris pas de drame en
douceur par exemple temelin chat le jury
trouve ça dégoûtant mais mes passions
tout ce que tu fais là on est une petite
femme qui était tout à toi la lâcher
comme ça comme une grue ça veut dire un
mot gentil mais oui ils ont déjà
interdit de parler aux impôts minable
être lancée pour le lâche à porto
oiseaux
par exemple toi tu me fais mal que
j'avais donnée tout mon coeur pour la
fiction tu me plaît mais cette fois je
t'en prie ce que tu peux nous ont rien
c'est la même chose ce que tu fais là
mystère mais c'est abominable
tu n'as aucune excuse vrai mais ce
serait qu'il fait vous empêcher de vous
disputer
c'est vrai tunnel c'est pas moi qui suis
lâché 1 à moi non plus on a eu la même
idée en même temps ça prouve que le
moment est venu
et naturellement tu as quelqu'un en vue
oui quelqu'un de bien - bien que toi
merci c'est au par mon pote ça nous
était pas que oui j'ai envie de porter
ton linge à toi c'est bon je vais
l'emporter
j'avais rangé mon sac dans l'armoire
j'aurais jamais cru qui me servirai
sitôt fédérer ces deux faux col et une
cravate ton pyjama au mon pauvre ami on
a connu de bien beaux moments ici tient
dans la poche un mouchoir à toi avec ton
taf apprend le bon quart d'heure le toit
on mange entre mais j'aime mieux pas moi
ça me rappellera des choses moi pendant
le toit des chemises de nuit
en cela je la reconnais tu vois ces
tacots je les fais le jour où on a
emménagé ici
enfin la nuit quoi tu te souviens tu
l'avais raccommoder très mal cette nuit
là didon c'est peut-être très bête que
nous faisons leur bateau et on a été
heureux ensemble
à ses yeux de mauvais moment des faits
en a vu d'autres au fleix peut-être
mieux de rester tous les deux botteurs
alors par quoi unis pour ses formes sur
robert doit pas de quoi vous mêlez vous
vous vous n'avez pas droit d'empêcher
une est de faire sa vie tout même ce pan
navire pourrait ne rester toujours avec
vous des toiles non l'esl a parlé à la
région c'est vrai que je ne suis pas
d'avenir pour toi moi ou travers ses
frais une séparation éternelle
je trouverais bien le moyen de
m'échapper de temps en temps au nom ma
petite ginette n'ont tué plus de moi je
sais pas ça moi je veux bien t'avoir à
moi même je ne veux pas de partager
c'est plus chic 14,82 dire là moi je
vais bien t'avoir à moi mais pas de
partager ça m'a tout remué et ben dis
donc moi je n'aurais jamais eu cette
idée là ô mon chéri tu es pas tant que
ça n'a rien que de très naturel c'est
fait tu sais mon petit rat verges
t'oublierai pas dans la vie tu t'en
apercevoir à jour
à quoi il a enfin qu'est ce que tu peux
faire pour moi j'aime comprend un
matelas de la chance il émit déduit vous
savez quoi déjà bah oui c'est vrai mais
il faut que je m'en aille à cette brave
amélie elle pense à tout âge
adieu ginette voilà tacler soit heureuse
tu m'embrasses prononce j'aurais peur de
m'attendrir tu as bien pris tout ce qui
est fait à toi oui tu veux les saints
n'ont qu'à donner la mairie
ça me fera une compagnie adieu aux
preuves rdp choc minière tabally la
raison tient aliette moi mettons l'âge
mais que chiffonné et 20 ans si on
repassera moi ça me gênait pour vous il
a mis des fleurs partout il en avait
juste que ce siège
toute la poule et au final un mariage
tout mais semaine d'après les avis elle
était plus chaud même pas l'oublier
bon alors héros vous les mettez vos les
emportements j'aimerais plus belle a
mahdia jolidon au boulot que je suivais
ne pourrait pas les portes et non mais
ça va venir je la passerai ma fille
pourquoi cette fin la noce quel âge elle
a 9 ans mais voici une voiture était en
boxe est fait marquer cette date la
femme de ménage à la femme de ménage
allait très bien la femme de ménage
paraît bien vous avez tout le monde tout
le monde mais vous aussi bien à
mystérieux on cherchera sa voie là bon
eh bien allons déjeuner et bon
restaurant
je pense bien mais qu'elle veut je ne
sais pas vous savez moi je suis comme
vous un j'ai jamais fait la noce moi je
me lance j'ai une idée j'ai enfin
accrocher de cercle il doit sûrement s'y
connaître
je lui demanderais de le conduire dans
un endroit chic ça va aller au revoir et
à bientôt
on se reverra du vous savez que vous
pouvez compter sur moi dans la vie vous
en apercevrez à jour ne me remerciez pas
je sais mais mon devoir abandonner
je vous en prie je veux tout le monde
soit heureux
voilà vous méme à côté
je suis mais je suis très heureux
[Applaudissements]
écoute mon petit c'est pas pour te faire
des reproches mais c'est le deuxième 6
gars que tu ligne depuis le déjeuner tu
fais une trop ça va très remarquée en
bas âge et des fois tu sais bien que je
m'appelle plus généreux ginette minces
dont c'était bon pour mon mari
ça sentait la fontaine geneviève ou deux
fort lange
ça fait mieux d'ailleurs je me suis
commandé du papier à lettres avec mes
initiales gf et madame is devises à une
dérive
oui liste c'est un mot anglais qui veut
dire un censeur
tu n'as pas l'air de me comprendre
ascenseur parce que je suis une femme
qui monte
1 pourquoi chaque bouffée de cigares
fais-tu faut pas autant possible
l'homme du monde de la femme du monde
doit éviter tous bruits inutiles telles
que tapotement trépignements moroni le
mans ronflements c'était patins je ne
sais pas si c'est un bon contact que tu
le dois
mais je te trouve chaque jour plus
distingués ça ne peut-être bientôt
compte à ma petite ginette jean piat et
moi j'aime mieux taper gina tu habitués
quoi tu penses toujours tanala entre ton
corps et ton ses sacres écolo que tu me
fais porter moi ça me gêne oui mais
c'est plus distingués ces grosses
et depuis six mois que nous connaissons
tous n'est pas petit habitude pas quand
on apporte une école d'appels entrants
entend bien c'est comme ces souliers
vernis va pas tant il me gêne sera pas
encore non non j'ai mon bureau dans une
heure très bien pourquoi satan lui je
m'endors ah oui et puis j'aimerais que
tu sois là quand reviendra robert va
venir
oui j'ai lu et écrit pour lui annoncer
qu'il avait trouvé une place et ben
c'est bien le tort que j'ai eu ma
tellement pas signer et tu l'attends
aujourd'hui à trois heures je veux pas
le voir
c'est pourquoi pourquoi enfin pourquoi
pourquoi parce que c'est immoral enfin
temps monsieur d'amis qui jaloux âge
projet loose pour genou donc c'est bien
qu'il aime plus c'est vrai que c'est
fini c'est d'actu la plus en vue mais
c'est pas une raison pour le rencontrer
voilà aura sept ans prit d'abord
j'aimerais que tu sois là pour lui
expliquer la place que tu lui as trouvé
je te le dis j'ai oublié at elle écrit
sur un papier tu n'est perdu mais je
vais te le répéter voila voila il s'agit
d'une poste de secrétaire chez mon ami
poulard faïenciers en gros 22 bis rue de
paradis entrée en fonction le 1er du
mois prochain à pointe moins 800 francs
par mois pour commencer à venir
excellence elle est sérieux conditions
avant d'en de montmartre des cabarets
des chansons one est pas difficile à se
rappeler non mais tu restes avec le
caractère qui m'a dépeint il accepte pas
il accepte son rapport il acceptera
parce que je le veux je veux faire son
panache à voile à sa marotte
elle veut faire le bonheur de tout le
monde jusqu'à chez lui de mes ouvriers
on va dire bien sûr il n'était pas assez
payés ces pauvres types comme chose de
proche de plus en plus d'ailleurs que je
te demandais à presque rien une
augmentation de 1 franc par jour
comme si ça valait la peine d'en parler
et à une façon de l'entendre le commerce
toi mais à 174 francs par jour 174
ouvriers ça fait soixante trois mille
cinq cent dix francs par an un érudit
comprenez rien ces gens là quand je leur
ai annoncé la chose de but en blanc
il a fallu que je leur explique que
j'avais une maîtresse un peu loufoque
merci enfin ils ont été comptable je te
crois les mots mêmes de mode et on
adresse pour te remercier bonnes gens
mais en attendant tu allais qui m'a dit
déplorable toi ma parole je me demande
si quelqu'un te montrent pas la cour en
fait c'est bien je le reçois jamais
personne alors madame c'est mademoiselle
amélie qui leur ai parlé à ma femme et
je crois bien
voilà des mois qu'on a vu or te voilà si
c'est pas malheureux sardes ont lâché à
faut pas m'en vouloir
fauchon mais c'est la boulangerie si
vous saviez ce qui m'arrive
vous connaissez eugène on roule on l'a
dit oui l'inventeur toutes ces
inventions rapport à non cette fois y
avait trouvé un truc est patent qu'il
détient sa fortune
un extenseur et pour les pantalons non
pour les incendies
alors un extincteur c'est ça une machine
a failli c'est moi je pouvais pas
laisser il avait pas d' incendies
soudaine ce matin justement j'étais en
train de me frisés j'ai mon petit
réchaud à alcool qui tombe par terre et
quiches le fait une serviette chalet
avec la serviette dans l'eau temps qui
me dit tu vas voir il court chercher son
appareil il loue et arosa serviette en
mai si vous aviez vu ça on a un instant
le feu s'est répandu partout les rites
auront l'armoire tout ya passé
le chef est ouvrier il est à l'hôpital à
ses bienfaits quant à l'appartement que
tu m'as donné il existe un plus il ya
plus des choses vous marquez pu alors
suis venu ici
croyez vous que ces flux temps pour
suivre un homme vrai langer pas de 20
points à moi cette histoire à sa fiche
des secousses que des fois je me demande
si j'étais fait pour faire la teuf
madame
il ya là cinq hommes qui prépare les à
madame comme re5 messieurs pas nous
mêmes ce sont pas des messieurs ils
sentent lag un tube in un jeu en lots et
je crois qu'ils ont des intentions sur
madame 2 attention oui l'emporté à
bouquet et un paquet qui m'ont donné ce
papier les employés de la maison racinet
labeaume envoient leurs remerciements
une délégation et un objet d'art à
mademoiselle jeunes viennent de forme de
lego sûrement que plus qs est pas vrai
alors une délégation et moi eh ben c'est
ça qui n'est pas ordinaire
tu viens avec moi penses-tu débrouille
toi tout seul mais que leur dire mais là
n'aura qu'à les écouter je crois qu'ils
ont préparé un discours
j'aime mieux ça vous déboucherez une
bouteille de champagne ont la forme qu
il va pas du champagne tout de suite
dans du vin rouge suffire
une bouteille de vin d'office très bien
ça attends moi un instant je reviens
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
là est pas c'est encore une idée du net
mes employés augmente et les employés
mellal top dans le corps la parole par
moment j'en ai par dessus la tête moi
elle avoue n'être pas heureux comme ça
je suis pas heureux mais pourquoi vous
dites que je suis pas heureux en libye
je prendrai très heureux que moi
tractations mari pendant près d'un mois
je fais beaucoup plus heureux si je
n'aimais pas la manie de répandre la
féliciter autour d'elle ce sont mes
employés ses robes et à son ancien ami
qu'il a fallu caser c'est madame berne
où la femme de ménage à qui j'ai dû
acheter un fonds de coca sièges
d'appoint cocasse hier c'est parce que
c'est qu'une coquille à 17h54 la femme
d'un caucus
non c'est une marchande de falla coke
s'est enquis de la concierge dont il a
fallu que je sois le parrain ah non
alors il m'a fait trop cher alors pas du
tout mais leurs produits tout bête mais
non mais si c'était pour elle chacun
comptant seulement j'ai pas pris une
maîtresse pour enrichir des gigolos des
bonniches et des pipelettes voilà en
gros ce qui vaut à faire branler j'ai
tout laissé il ya une plaque gravée nos
plaques ou ce jour alors bienfaitrice
geneviève de forts relents les ouvriers
reconnaissance grotesque tu mens liens
afin vas tu pourrais bien être content
parce que je suis content moi moi il
s'agit bien de moi c'est mon associé qui
veille sur les racines et tu n'as pas
encore d'où j'ai pas osé et c'est
aujourd'hui qu'ils vers vérifier les
cordes etc ce qui va dire c'est monsieur
ostim des gouttes aux racines et non des
écoutes
attiki à des millions armée à l'appel
hurlaient pour quelques malheureux
billets de 1000
d'abord si cris trop fort tu n'as qu'une
chose à faire tu mulamba moi je m'en
charge de ton racine est justement ce
soir nous avons une l'aja l'opéra et
bien invite le jeu ne s'est pas fâcher
les faire sa connaissance
qu'est ce que tu lui diras tu verras ce
serait bien l'amadouer ce ne sera pas
facile parce que je connais racines et
moi il est pas galant avec cris femme
n'est même pas lui sont différentes
valeurs festivités dans la nuit
aïe aïe bas qui s'ennuie à crier en file
indienne et j'ai une idée
quant à lui coller amélie moi je veux
bien oui marchera pas il marchera je
veux faire le bonheur d'un mass eye and
co n'ont cessé de maladie et celui de
racine est quand on devra sa maîtresse
il n'aura plus rien ou refuser si tu
viendras ce soir l'opéra avec nous
j'accepte tremblant elles sont là suis
je te retrouve une des miels ma femme
c'est chiant de la mettra sa taille ça
va moi je veux bien alors c'est convenu
tu habites racines et à l'opéra puisque
tu tiennes haut
14h32 le bureau à saint berthevin et
aider à mettre ton par dessus bord le
plus la can et le phare dessus de
monsieur clients des gants des gants est
utile des camps oui j'étais au gré à la
main puis mettre à bas taux manach à
bongo nokia n'est faut que je mette ce
morceau de verre dans l'oeil oui
je veux que mon avance mascheffa il sera
chic que la mariée sera chic des braves
au train le monde
[Musique]
ouais ce qui m'embête mais ce qui
m'embête c'est si la scène qui va me
faire à signer alors ton chapeau il est
là mon chapeau plein ça va comme ça
[Applaudissements]
le pauvre petit il en a une frousse de
son racinaire tu sais mon petit c'est
pas pour dire mais tu lembeck stop tht a
fait ces confidences oui il est mal ou
non mais des fois tu lui coûter la maaf
attenti à ses formats qu'il est
demandeur mariage puis c'est entre nous
et nous ça sera long et une magic qui
sont racinet et moi je me charge de les
raccorder faudra signer et ma robe
je vais m'en occuper
c'est la couleur qui devait le rouge
pour aller à l'opéra
vous sortirez maroc pleut et vous la
mettrais à la taille de mademoiselle
vient madame ou mademoiselle k tel avec
moi le long de reims dans un instant
c'est pas tout ça mais va falloir tâcher
d'être à la hauteur en toilettes de
vannes
mais ça ne suffit pas tout à l'heure mon
professeur va venir un professeur va
bien c'est une femme ne peut arriver
dans la vie qu'en ayant un professeur je
lui dirai d'être donné quelques conseils
un professeur qu'est ce qui t'a peau
mate ou un hachoir à me lever à marcher
à manger à parler ainsi toi comment tu
causes utiles position qu'on parle des
littérateurs devant toi qu'est-ce que tu
diras bas rien
alors tu auras l'air d'une gourde moi je
dis je doute fort gabriel d'annunzio il
exprime des sentiments et pernelle dans
une langue savoureuse aux peintures les
derniers salons étaient à des pauvres
mais j'ai noté toutefois quelques ventes
dont on guette mais de le facturer tout
dix ans tu meurs on parle musique j'ai
rafale de moussorsgki son harmonie et
d'un art subtil et prenant mehdi vous
l'entendre plusieurs fois avant que de
la bile goûter au but alors voilà ma
chère ce qui s'appelle posée madame
c'était un monsieur qui voudraient par
les eaux
amélie poste par ici quelques instants
baird à venir te prendre des mesures
c'est aux professeurs n'ont pas encore
je te ferai prévenir
mademoiselle geneviève de formage gnet
sujet ne m étais tout le plaisir que ça
te fait nos verres ça que signifie j'ai
reçu une lettre signée geneviève de fort
l'an passé - j'ai changé de nom mais il
écriture j'ai changé d'écriture aussi à
c'était un piège
oui je comprends vous vous êtes dit si
je signe ginette il ne viendra pas et
vous avez raison je n'ai rien à faire
ici je m'en vais moi tant vers quoi
alors ce que tu peux être hérissé tu
sais même pas ce que je vais te demander
une question d'abord nous sommes
toujours des étrangers l'un pour l'autre
oui alors je vous prierais de ne plus me
tutoyez c'est plus correct quand il
voudra comme vous voudrez parler je vous
écoute
asseyez-vous soit tu te rappelles quand
tu m'as vous vous rappelez quand tu m'as
ensuite que c'est dur de dire si vous
quand on s'est dit que tu te crois que
je te tutoie non bon alors vous vous
rappelez quand nous nous sommes quittés
je vous avais dit que je me tue près de
nous oui alors alors je les ai trouvé
une place quoi une plainte de secrétaire
chez un faïenciers en gros non mais vous
plaisantez je pensais alors vous avez
cru que j'allais accepté de me faire
entretenir par vous or vous avez de ces
mots entretenir ou 8e j potes ça mais ça
revient au même
ça suffit mais ça ne se fait pas et il
faut que vous soyez inconsciente comme
vous l'êtes pour avoir seulement osé me
proposez vous êtes protease à g à la fin
c'est vrai tu enfonces on a mal de chien
ou des carcasses pour rendre service qui
apprécient les remercia tout point non
mais c'est vrai aussi j'ai fait ça c'est
parce que ça me rappelle la région de
tell on a été heureux ensemble
et puis c'est parce qu'on s'est quitté
gentiment proprement de façon à pouvoir
se rencontrer plus tard faut faire la
tête
j'ai été un peu dur je vous demande
pardon
c'est mon défaut je sèche alors vous
accepter ça ce n'est pas possible
réfléchissez un peu hein est ce que
c'est une situation d'être chansonnier
mais parfaitement ma dernière chanson ça
me picotte dans les orteils leur
apporter 170 francs 170 francs mon petit
robert il arrive un moment dans la vie
où il faut se ranger où il faut songer à
l'avenir vous parlez comme une
bourgeoise c'est que j'ai réfléchi on
n'a pas droit de rester immobile quand
autour de soi tout accompli une marche à
sandor dites moi vous voyez toujours le
type que j'ai vu une fois rue fontaine à
le professeur de belle manière
oui pourquoi pour rien nous disiez je
dis c'est que vous aussi vous devriez
tâche est de monter plus haut et
d'améliorer votre situation mais ma
chère amie que voulez-vous que j'aille
de faire dans la faïencerie cheveux ni
autant y avait mon cher à nice il ne
s'agit pas de vendre des petits pots
enfin monsieur couleur est un homme
considérable qui à son loto il a besoin
d'un bras droit intelligent cultivé
homme du monde tout à fait votre affaire
en se frottant plaisir si vous vouliez
bien un
j'ai rendu service à tout le monde
excepté à vous et c'est justement avoue
surtout à vous que je voudrais rendre
service
bah vous êtes vraiment gentille alors
c'est convenu non quand ce ne serait que
pour me récompenser toute la peine que
j'ai prise vous savez la paluche le
tanin ce pour edouard les douars qui
s'essaye doit la vie parce que c'est
votre ami qui me procure cette place là
bien sûr c'est à lui je me suis adressé
au saas et le couple et vous ne lisiez
pas et jallet accepter a décidément pas
chers amis il ya des choses que vous ne
comprendrez jamais et bien tant pis pour
vous mais moi je ne mange pas de ce
pain-là relais plaisamment je vous dis
adieu ginette me faire casey par votre
amant par mon successeur a assez du joli
et j'allais consentir ouah ouah
y'a pas à dire me n'était pas de temps
attention les professeurs de madame est
là et vous l'avez fait attendre mais
j'étais entré bien vide
ensuite vous enverrez mademoiselle
amélie bien madame monsieur le
professeur dé matin bonjour ma chair et
d'os vos journaux métro et rewe il ya la
fin je ne suis pas en retard non je suis
exact projet du mérite vous avez porté
chance
les leçons affluent elle est vraiment
charmant autres jeux sortent chez à
l'aide de givre en vous quittant je
cours chez solange de beaugency mon taxi
matam à la porte
je n'en peux plus je lis suffit plus je
refuse du monde je ne donne pas mes
songes les accords noués tel fatigue mon
dieu je me dévoue à l'est oui non je
n'ai pas le temps non
avez vous travaillé aujourd'hui oui et
répété la leçon d'hier la réception il a
bien marché mais j'en suis sûr vous irez
très loin et très haut
parce que vous avez la qualité
essentielle les ans mais tout est là
qu'on vous allez aux folies bergères et
que vous voyez les jongleurs qu'admirer
vous on ne leur adresse ils n'ont leur
essence étaient ils ont l'air de penser
à autre chose
et bien tout est là dans la vie on ne
doit pas se remuer il faut évoluer avec
grâce et avec souplesse comme si on
pensait à autre chose et c'est votre cas
vous êtes la meilleure de mes élèves je
suis sûr que vous lui dites à toute
parole de gentilhomme nom de l'écuyère
j'ai demandé sa démission d'élèves à
lise montre lieux une femme qui se cogne
dans les guéridons et qui bute dans les
coussins enfin j'ai renoncé j'ai renoncé
une selle et la pleurer elle est raide
et à mes pieds ça inutile dans la vie
privée je peux sourire mais quand il
s'agit de mon art je suis inflexible
travaillons
avant de commencer m voulez vous
m'autorisez à vous présenter une de mes
amies
mademoiselle a mis le marcheur enfin
possible en fait malgré votre
recommandation cependant toute puissante
je pourrais toutefois si mademoiselle
veut prendre un numéro d'or je la ferai
ça vous bénéficiez d'un ton papa non non
mais il ne s'agit pas de nouvel élève
mais mon ami veut nous rejoindre ce soir
à l'opéra et je voudrais qu'elle assiste
à la laisse encore quand je préfère
travailler son témoin avoue gelé rial a
refusé rester bas 3 l je vous accorde
l'autorisation
merci monsieur
ces petits pois savoir quel ça c'est
ainsi bouger plus sur toutes ces sales
exemple des pêcheurs est comme ça
commence
nous allons entamer aujourd'hui la 23e
le son la séance au théâtre vous y allez
ce soir m'avez-vous oui quel est le
programme de votre soirée
je dis non café de paris avec la bo mon
ami café de paris avec la paume de là ne
nous rendent aux à l'opéra pour entendre
chose il a retenu l'injure à nous
rejoindre sont associés monsieur racine
il est mon ami ainsi que voici viendra
nous rejoindre on la présentera monsieur
racine est à qui elle de ne pas plaire
je me suis engagé
l'habitation
bon nous allons exécuter ce propre comme
cette leçon est un peu plus compliquée
que les précédentes
j'ai amené mon accessoiristes il attend
dans l'onshore auguste auguste table de
restaurant deux personnes nous allons
imaginer que le repas est finie inutile
de rêver 17 de son vous la savez parfois
mon dieu quelle horreur enlevé 7 et 8
ans et sa petite fille de huit montus
plus vite auguste je fatigue du monde le
sait mais cette règle comment cette
femme de tête reste à sion
le dessert est terminée auguste d'un air
distrait vous trempez l'extrémité de vos
doigts dans le bol d'eau tiède
non non non non non ne regardez pas vos
mains causer avec moi avoir l'air de
penser à autre chose que vous connaissez
la dernière
dans cet extrait vous essuyez vos doigts
avec la petite glace de votre trousse
vous vérifiez votre figure au besoin
vous la saupoudrer walo délicatement
avec votre groupe est à poudre de riz
très plus plus plus plus vif émoi mais
ciel nous nous levons le garçon du
vestiaire temps d'abord votre pénis
non c'est moi qui doit vous aider il est
inadmissible que les mains mercenaires
frôle vos épaules
n'oubliez pas qu'elle signe car vous
êtes en trois lettres de soi ni la bombe
ne met jamais labeaume s'est pas vie sa
seule loto de man a neigé pas d'auto la
bande prend toujours des taxis
ça viendra
grimes un taxi
je mets mon par dessus pendant ce temps
vous promener sur les dîneurs un regard
dédaigneux et comme absent hier à midi
vidéogramme nous sortons je vous fais
part c'est me vont le taxi n'est pas
encore là et il peut vous paraître
canaille qu'une personne de votre rang
doivent l'attendre sur le trottoir mais
vous avez une peau lisse de l'autre et
il est bon que les gens la fois des
badauds s'arrêtent un gamin saisi
d'admiration laisse tomber son mégot
vous vous ou lycées de cette curiosité
sans en avoir l'air le taxi est arrivé
nous montons merci ne dit pas merci le
chauffeur n'existe pas pour vous vous ne
voyez même pas la portière s'est ouverte
tout seul à salies
à l'opéra
l'auto se met en route vous dit quelques
mots d'un air las on a bien dîner ce
soir nous ont dit on a mal manche et
s'est mieux portée
il faut toujours laisser supposer que
votre ordinaire est infiniment supérieur
on veut pas que vous venez de faire vous
pouvez cependant faire l'éloge d'un plat
mais pas plus
au moment d'arriver vous dites qu est-ce
qu on joue ce soir
vous devez être sensé ignorer ces deux
bons coups nous sommes arrivés
l'ouvreur de portières se précipitent
l'ouvreur des ports thiès vegas puis les
sources dont le personnel et on les paie
un prix ou vous il tend la main pour
vous aider à descendre mais je préviens
son geste et je passe le premier pour
vous soutenir le coude il faut toujours
éviter le contact des gens qui ne sont
pas nés ou qui n'ont pas cent mille
livres de rands pour le moins
vous pouvez cependant lui adresser un
sourire quoi ce départ d'un garçon bien
salariés vous pouvez lui faire cette
aumône
d'autant plus qu'il s'agit probablement
d'un homme du monde rues minées par les
phares d'un geste gracieux vous ramassez
le bas de votre lourd de fourrure et de
votre jeu et nous montons l'escalier
pour nous rendre à notre nom
sas
nous arrivons nous entrons la pièce est
déjà commencée ah non incite les gens du
monde n'arrive qu'à la fin du premier à
la bôme la bourgogne toujours arriver
avant le lever du rideau society qui
comprend pas chez montus cet homme est à
toi s'il avoue intervient travaillons
travaillons pas pour les 8 mai pour le
fin connaisseur dont vous êtes digne
nous entrons aussitôt arrivé sur le
devant de la loge bien en vue vous
laissez tomber votre pénis d'un air
l'église gens ne vous retournez pas
soyez tranquilles votre ami va être là
pour l'art il ya plus de la baume vous
l'avez pas vous en occuper il la pose
des monstrueuses mans au fond de la
halle à vous jeter dans la salle un
regard circulaire non non non non pas
dans leur quête les premières loges
seulement
votre lorgnette s'arrête un instant sur
une rivale de beauté et d'élégance vous
la toise et
c'est très bien puis nous tournant vers
moi vous faites sur elle à haute voix
une remarque désobligeante à haute voix
mais puisqu'on champs les gens bien
élevés par le canton chanter se taisent
quand on danse asseyons est bien vous
vous est compté non non non non non
comme ça tu as fait du vent avec les
cheveux délicatement
la pièce suit son cours et mademoiselle
amélie fait son entrée
et quelque chose mais dans une très
belle va pas rester là comme ça n'ont
qu'à les regarder mon père un tournoi
olalala mais pas par deux ans n'avait
pas indélébile ongles par derrière par
vous entrez dans la loge voilà vous
aurez la petite porte à vous vous entrez
dites bonjour à votre ami jean danjou
non non dans la loge d'à côté on peut
vous entendre de la distinction dit
bonjour rochelle et non pas des gains
avec capture l emprunter la passe on a
essayé mais non pas là devant
mademoiselle vous êtes dit le femme là
je ne la supporte lapd se termine
pendant l'entracte arrive racine est
alors là je cesse d'être la bombe
1 je suis rassis j'entre vous ne
connaissez pas bien
labeaume vous présente il vous baise la
main
il s'incline devant mademoiselle ne vous
levez pas mademoiselle nous est une
femme un petit salut de la tête
simplement ne le regardais pas en face
aussitôt après le petit salut tu voulais
tourner les yeux
avoir l'air de penser à autre chose
[Applaudissements]
bon c'est autre chose c'est tout l'art
du monde
voilà encore aux ponts cause des
critiques on parle musique naturellement
vous vous servez votre petite phrase sur
mon saut à skis et vous vous dites
cette musique de gounod un charme
vieillot qui plaît tant aux cas oui mais
moi oui dites là c'est plus et 2 go no
un charmant vieillard qui plaît encore
gellion payant
et puis vous n'ont pas d'eau non mais
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un gounod
mais c'est l'auteur de la pièce
mademoiselle vous ne connaissez pas la
pièce non moi non plus
il faut au moins que vous en connaissiez
le sujet le voici en deux on me regarde
un vieux savant faust se dit à la fin
bien d'actes et j'ai été assez bête de
travail et toute ma vie au lieu de faire
la nasse avec de jolies petites femmes
et ils vont son âme au diable qui lui
ronge sa jeunesse il rencontre une jeune
fille du meilleur mon goût de marguerite
à qui il propose de dormir ensemble
elle refuse mais il lui offre un collier
de perles
alors là elle marche tous dessus et il
lui fait un enfant mais ça la gêne cette
petite d'avoir avoué sa ses parents
alors elle étrangle en sont morts et
puis elle meurt à la suite de quoi elle
va tout droit au paradis
ça je suis surpris que vous ne
connaissiez pas fausses comme tous les
parents y mènent leurs enfants c'est la
pièce idéale pour jeunes filles akela
key ce qu'on voit le petit donc en fait
que nous ne le voit pas mademoiselle
mais moi j'aime tant ça quand on voit
des enfants dans les pièces ça me fait
pleurer
oui eh bien je crois que pour séduire
monsieur racine est le mieux et que vous
ne lui parlez pas trop vous prendrez une
pose alanguie il encore non non non le
coude
appuyez sur le bord de la loge comme ça
très bien
si vous interroge vous ne répondrez que
par monosyllabes par quoi
vous lui direz oui non
pas plus voilà rien d'autre à vous dire
pour le restant de la soirée voilà prêt
suit son cours j'oubliais il ya
cependant le moment où vous devrez c'est
quand tu marques je ne savais pas que ma
tasse à la mairie travail est aussi jeu
mais pour lui demander d'essayer la robe
vas-y amélie n'est ce pas m vous lui
permettez europe les commandes ont jeu
l'ont pris en forme si l on voit mon
enfant au revoir car telle est la
réponse à des prêts des ménages
on croit rêver
[Applaudissements]
ma pauvre petite celle elle ne fera
jamais rien et elle le fera jamais
personne si vous croyez que l'on promeut
racines et pourtant il le faut je les
prenais je peux vous prédire que c'est
manquer d'avant je vous disais donc il
ya un moment où vous devrez applaudir
c'est quand marguerite aura chanté l'air
des bijoux un celui qui commence par ces
mots c'est la chanson si on peut plus
chanter ça me rappelle de l'asie je ris
de me voir si belle en ce miroir jory de
participants applaudissaient
non non non non pas c'est fort non dans
la loge d'un côté il peut y avoir des
gens qui dorment
comme ça bravo bravo bravo
1 2 3 à granby
qu'est ce que tu fais là toi et toi
pourquoi arrive qu'à cette heure-ci
atelier donc pas de bureau apple s'en
passe de belles au bureau je ne mettrai
pas moi d'abord d' qu'est ce que c'est
que ce monsieur que je vous fabriquer
tous les élans cette boîte
monsieur edouard la bande mon ami le
comte de stanislav de la ferronnière
professeur de belle manière manière à tu
prend des leçons de belle manière dont
va bien chez une femme de [ __ ] arriver
dans la vie qu'en apprenant à devenir
distinguer et monsieur me la met
aujourd'hui de leçons de fait c'est pas
pour toi les leçons pour devenir
distingué après six ans goûte à sac qui
doit d'être venu schisteuses et maniéré
ah bravo monsieur vous avez fait du bel
ouvrage et ginette plaisait mais avant
avoue peut-être monsieur mais pas à tout
le monde à tout le monde mais la
maîtresse libre à tout le monde monsieur
évidemment la maîtresse et amant une
part tout le monde est gagnant
c'est sans doute aussi à vous que je
dois ses observations sur ma façon de me
tenir à nove tir soudain bon que je dois
si grand que gm essaie souvient qu'il
partirait il faut souffrir pour être
beau est-ce que vous manqueriez de moi
par exemple je m'en garderais bien ou
des noirs soient gentils les papillons
de prendre à ce jeu c'est ma chère
élèves je reviendrai une autre fois
voilà parfois mais je vous prie de ne
plus remettre les pieds monsieur
renoncer à lestonan me dis donc tu m'a
pas regardée mais monsieur je reviendrai
si madame de fort lange le désir groupe
mais qu'est ce qu'elle mettre ici 1
qu'est ce qui peut l'appartement dont
film ce que fit comment ça fait
il m'appelle fille maintenant je suis là
et je vous allume de l'élection à moi
aussi impossible monsieur tout mon temps
j'ai pris un coup alors monsieur je vous
prie de prendre la porte et je ne veux
plus jamais vous revoir ici ou
m'attendais aussi le roi où je me sens
que mon aïeul système de la ferronnière
chambellan du roi louis 15 fut un jour
frappé à coups de poings par importe
fait le lendemain sa majesté des liasses
informé de sa santé et lui demander des
nouvelles des coups qu'il avait reçu
sir lui répondu mon ancêtre nous autres
gentilshommes nous ne sentons pas le
point nous ne sentons que les coups
d'épée si vous désirez monsieur que de
nous coupions la gorge
je suis votre sinon je parle
[Applaudissements]
voilà mal élevés pour saluer quelqu'un
veut aller lui ici c'est pas lui
en fait on avait besoin d'interrompre
façon 1 ce soir à l'opéra devant racines
et j'aurais l'air du noir à l'opéra il
s'agit bien l'opéra à l'initiation
m'enraciner à l'opéra pas ce qui s'est
passé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce que j'avais
prévu quand je vous annonce comme ça
m'agace ce truc quand je lui ai annoncé
l'observatoire ma tâche ne m'avait
accordé aux ouvriers mais ça a été une
scène il m'a dit qui s'y refusait que ça
se passerait pas comme ça qu'il vaut
mieux fermer la maison folie et
dégoûtant ce type là et qui fit il a
répondu je lui ai dit que c'était une
idée at war oui alors là et alors on
s'est fâché tout rouge
il a déclaré qu'il avait venir ici pour
te priés de se mêler de ce qui le
regarde voilà ici quand soirs de suite
il invite d'ailleurs moi c'est parfait
j'essaie d'avoir changé 32e puis je
compte aussi dur que le panel va faire
pas tout j'étais ici ah non monsieur je
vais faire un tour c'est ça dans une
heure quand tu reviendras qu'il sera
arrangée à te croirais oui à l'image de
promettre un bel instant
taillez la lumière maintenant fait
entrer la réception et d'opter troisième
leçon à albacete
[Applaudissements]
je ne suis pas fâché de vous voir et de
vous dire ce que j'ai sur le coeur et
moi aussi cher monsieur je suis ravi de
vous connaître
mon ami m'a si souvent parler la bombe
est un mythe uruguay en bout je voulais
vous dire quand je vous en prie par les
plus bas j'ai une migraine affreux non
pas voyez jeu reposait en lisant tintin
j'étais plongé dans la chartreuse de
parme a décidément c'est un intérêt
sable shader oui oui peut-être
je voulais vous dis on je vous demande
pardon et je vous tiens debout mais
asseyez-vous non merci vont acquérir ses
lettres je prends l'été vous allez le
prendre avec non merci je n'ai pas le
temps d'être désobliger riz infiniment
en acceptant je vous assure ce serait me
faire afro com/fr l'été ici et qu'on me
dérange par la jolie simon personnes
je suis trop contente de pouvoir d'avoir
des quelques instants avec l'homme
d'esprit qu'on a dit que vous étiez vous
êtes trompés mais je voulais vous parler
d'un petit incident qui vient de se
produire au bureau et dont vous êtes un
con je suis heureuse de pouvoir en cause
et avec mon ami monsieur labeaume est un
excellent tome que j'aime beaucoup et
qui fait ce que je vais demander sans
comprendre
il ne comprend pas le plaisir délicat
que j'éprouve à répandre un peu de mon
bonheur autour de moi et je suis sûr que
vous qui êtes si faim car il ya qu à
bavarder avec vous sa visite pour voir
que vous êtes intelligent on me l'a dit
quelquefois je suis sûr que vous sentez
que c'est qu'il ya des doux à consacrer
une part ben une toute petite part de
votre immense fortune à faire un peu de
bien
1 quant à l'augmentation votre à fortis
mais c'est un pas considérable si on m'a
dit que vous ne saviez pas le compte
on a exagéré oh oui je suis sûr que si
labeaume ne vous avais pas parlé de
l'augmentation de vos employés vous en
seriez même pas aperçu parfois c'est
bien précis mais si le thé
qu'il était quand je tendrais d
interdire et mademoiselle amélie coup je
veux servir - mais monsieur racine
prenez les vêtements donnez nous la wii
bien mais votre migraine mais c'est ici
par votre vue fort ou léger effort un
peu de crème
si vous voulez et deux morceaux de sucre
cuit
merci
avec le thé je vous recommande un de ces
petits gâteaux non merci non non je n'ai
pas photo c'est une spécialité de la
maison des fours et de foie gras avec
des lamelles de salades saupoudré d'un
soupçon de parmesan
dans ce cas délicieux où je suis désolé
d'être entré si violemment
j'ai interrompu votre lecture j'ai gagné
au change
il est vrai que j'aime beaucoup dire
avez vous vu le dernier roman de gabriel
d'annie duke la non j'ai bout de force
et écrivain il exprime des sentiments
aux éternels dans une langue savoureuse
oui peut-être enfin je vous avoue que je
les lis forte à je vois vous préférez
sans doute la peinture la peinture vous
savez la peinture vous visitez le
dernier salon d'automne apoel il était
un peu pauvre mais j'ai la tête
toutefois quelques ventes dans guerre
mais de leur facture étourdissante
je vous avoue je vais fort peu aux
expositions ah je vois vous aimez la
musique
bon la musique vous savez la musique moi
je raffole de moussorsgki son harmonie
et d'un art subtil prenant mais il faut
l'entendre plusieurs fois avant que dell
a bien voté mais c'est bien possible
vous savez j'entends si rarement de la
musique
au sam vous devez vous ennuyer dans la
vie je ne m'ennuie pas jma somme il ya
des moments où je me rappelle tellement
que j'ai envie de me marier vous mariez
vous on a fait pas ça c'est trop jeune
trop gay trop vive propre alerte va
faire une fin de juin mais vous n'êtes
pas mûres à vous trouver
mais oui ce qu'il vous pose est une
petite maîtresse
jeanne est vivante qui occuperont
journée et charme votre existence
je gère le moment
très bien et toi permettez moi de vous
présenter une de mes amies
mademoiselle amélie de valve neige
monsieur racine viol mademoiselle
m
tiens formule à sept et buzz est
constituée femmes veulent apporter au
pire tu sais moi je te suis pas malade
j'aimerais mieux des petits gâteaux
on voit là
pourquoi est-elle en toilettes de balle
parce qu'elle va au théâtre
mon avis via nous rejoindre ce soir à
l'opéra tu es content de voir fausse
bourg sur j'aime bien l'auteur le petit
bouchon est un vieillard qui plaît
encore
mais je croyais qu'il était mort elle
parle de sa musique
il est souffrante mademoiselle
l'encours quoi elle était un peu
mélancolique
après quelques années d'une folle
passion son amant vient d'acquitter les
cheveux libres allemand des fois que je
trouverai quelqu'un qui me plaît au pire
vous savez un mois ça m'est égal cas ne
soit pas joli joli
écoute mon petit la tuer puis à tarbes
qui n'est pas très gracieux tu devrais
demander à berthe de te l'arrangé hoyé
soir monsieur
je crois que les pâtés
[Applaudissements]
comment la trouvez-vous fâcheuses
menora les charpentes seulement elle
était un peu troublé en vous voyant reçu
ça je pense elle a tout à l'heure en
voyant tous les deux bien je pensais
qu'elle était peut-être l'occupation
qu'il vous manque et mais des femmes
comme elle j'en connais des tas on y
trouve à la douzaine comme les huîtres
n'en parlons plus mais je pense à ce que
vous me disiez tout à l'heure je crois
que c'est vous qui avez raison ce qu'il
me faudrait c'est une petite amie
seulement voila j'aimerais bien
quelqu'un qui vous ressemble
oh pardon je crois qu'il faut dire qui
vous ressemble à l'imparfait du
subjonctif et puis correct mais l
indicatif présent et plus usuels à vous
étiez patente à bala bonheur avec
gourmand on peut causer
sapristi sacré labeaume qui doit pas
s'embêter
vous savez la bombe il ne comprend pas
toujours n'oserait je dire que je les
dépasse est un peu vous êtes modeste
enfin pauvre labo faut pas lui en
vouloir il est le fils de ses oeuvres
avec vous vous êtes le fils de votre
père vous êtes très spirituel je suis
fille de ma mère
et elle habite l'esprit elle en était
pétri à sacrer d'abord je suis sûr qu'il
était incapable de vous appréciez c'est
dans ce que vous dites là c'est
exactement ce que me disait tout à
l'heure à de mes amis ou à la nuit de
simples affections wiki ça le côté
stanislas de la ferronnière le
descendant du célèbre chambellan de
louis 15
il m'a vu naître et il consent deux fois
par semaine à venir de transmettre les
traditions de politesse de l'ancien
régime
quelle merveilleuse et ginette à quand
on pense qu'un la boum logis une perle
au sirha dans un écrin aussi pau un
appartement de location vous devriez
avoir votre hôtel monsieur labeaume est
indigne de vous et quand on pense que
c'est à moi qui vous dois voir si je
vous avez connu à cette époque là qu'est
ce qu'ils auraient fait je vous en
regardez pour - pas moi j'aurais su vous
comprendre j'aurais si vous estimez à
votre juste valeur
mme gina jean et si vous voulez mon ami
mais que me demandez-vous là enfin vous
allez vivre c'est impossible
edwards était très gentil pour moi et je
ne veux pas quitter
vous savez vous avez pu rentrer dans
votre intérêt mélangeant le chien oui
parfaitement dans celui de la boum
est ce que vous croyez que cet homme là
est heureux avec vous mais oui non je
voulais affirme je le sais la banque je
ne savais plus à un temps un noceur lui
c'est un bourgeois bourgeoise crois que
ça l'a vu sortir tous les soirs avec
vous d'aller au théâtre et de rentrer à
deux heures du matin pas du tout les
seuls bons moments qu'il passe avec vous
dont ils me parlent avec attendrissement
sont les soirées qu'ils passent ici
oui jean avez-vous avec ses petits plats
préférés et oui il somnole en ronronnant
au coin du feu
oser dire que ce n'est pas si c'est vrai
vous voulez bien me bousculer et là je
ne dis pas non mais laissez moi
réfléchir
tu l'entends qui vient catella haut à
l'or les écossais a oui ça je suis sous
le charme
quelle femme délicieux elle est gentille
alors pour l'augmentation s'est arrangé
ça l'augmentation à wimmis parfaitement
tout ce qu'elle voudra ah bon ah bon
je suis content alors je suis très
content très content alors le père
d'enis ma silva à l'opéra mais bien sûr
qu'on y va à l'opéra à bon port à
l'opéra didon ça n'a pas l'air te faire
tellement plaisir là je suis si mais tu
sais le mal est sorti du sort je suis
pas fou qu'est ce que je vous disais
enfin si ça vous amuse tout non mais dis
donc pas l'augmentation ces comprimés
oui ça ne fait jamais que 174 fois par
jour soixante trois mille cinq cent dix
francs par an donc ça oui oui je fais
les comptes je voulais voir oui non tu
permets un instant et quant à jean tu
viens excusez je suis moi
[Applaudissements]
alors que j'avais un petit revenu tout à
l'heure rodez lui soit possible
je lui dis que madame ginette je suis
content de vous trouver
je tenais à m'excuser pour ma sortie
tout à l'heure oui évidemment je
comprends vous ne pouvez rien accepter
de mon amour a évidemment et s'il
n'était plus mon amant alors la une
depuis aucun problème
tout est possible mais leur vie et vous
allez le remercier vous lui devez bien
non je vous en prie et toi ma femme je
connais monsieur
et oui moi de même c'est vous qui
regardez les petites femmes à la
lorgnette
c'est vous qui jeté les bouquets par les
fenêtres oui c'est donner beaucoup de
mal pour vous trouver une situation
c'est à monsieur je vous remercie
il n'y a pas de quoi non mais vous les
bons rendements plus non mâcon alors que
je me suis donné beaucoup moins de mal
que ginette 9 bis n'ont plus cours et
vous que mon ami poule a les cheveux
cieux je vous le présenterai tout à
l'heure alors votre réponse
ce serait oui si j'étais sûr que ça ne
passera de chagrin je ne lui en fera pas
en fassiez un petit peu au début il
criera pendant dix minutes et il nous
remerciera pendant dix ans que j'en suis
sur les guidons rachid et vient m'aider
à convaincre ce jeu l'algérie pomme
les bains à des criminels sabich non tu
n'as vraiment pas de plaindre il va te
tomber le dossier de ville en or sur la
tête
en cet appartement te plaît non et bien
au chaud je t'en fais cadeau disciples
féminines
il est dû de 36 ans a alors monsieur
vous n'acceptez pas à cela m'est
absolument impossible je ne vous en
remercie pas moins d'ailleurs rapidement
pour quoi faire
enfin vous vous savez la raison elle
n'existe plus
aa et doit y il accepte aux bravos ça un
peu entier ce jeune homme mais je ne
déteste pas c'est un de vos amis
un ancien ami le passé le présent
l'avenir
[Applaudissements]
hop
alors madame chiffres affolants dit oui
monsieur site ici non monsieur madame
est sorti je ne vais pas vous dire
monsieur c'est encore un journaliste et
elle passaient mal téléphone
feignant celui-là
alain alquier tel appareil
je te freineuse imparfaitement mais le
rédacteur du chic anglo français alors
voilà ce n'est pas encore concret non
mais je l'attends instant à l'autre
ah non ah non monsieur fenech non non je
ne suis pas monsieur racine est en
suisse un ami un ancien ami alors mais
je peux faire votre commission que cette
fameuse à une interview aulas est
difficile et très occupés aux est assez
poussé
demain au peut demain attendit demain
peut-être oui oui oui il ya une
possibilité demain à 3h30 exactement
entre la leçon de harpe et la manucure
non mais cic bien l'instant après il
sera trop tard
alors eh ben c'est tentant de monsieur
de cette dernière mesure de freiner mais
c'est saab a repris 2
friends
même si aso lui aient mari florent
manama est bien dit qu'elle soit de
retour à 5 heures oui monsieur payet 5e
rica rethel aller aux vernissages
automatique love avec monsieur
alors merci florent justement voici
madame à vous voilà enfin je suis cette
forme nouvelle route a fait attendre un
peu oui
alors c'était bien sûr un message un
monde fou tout paris à l étoile de la
derrière mes derniers oui ça va mon
pauvre ami c'était voyant ça et toi tu
reviens très bien très bien merci
il est mis devant l'absence oui madame
et de l'ingérer vasseur se fait moins
froid photographe
il m'avait pas de rendez vous je désire
oui vous avez bien fait je suis épuisé
voyez ce que c'est orange suisse au prix
du staa vous ne restez pas comme ça du
salon à vous d'en finir il donnait la
locale a bien joué de la part des dits
oui messieurs si madame est de retour
non monsieur madame n'est pas encore
rempli quand elle reviendra
madame ne rentrera pas bien monsieur
[Musique]
non mais vraiment il abusa il veut faire
mon portrait au crayon pour pari foot
une feuille qui tire à 3h et un sens aux
enfants et moi j'ai pris rendez vous
proposés diallo de demain là à 3h30 le
le chic anglo français pour sa série
direct de paris et bien je verrai ça
demain cela dépendra de l'état dans
lequel je serai en face les hommes sont
surprenants il vole qui me femmes
s'engagent pour le lendemain enfin le
lendemain celle ci je pourrais recevoir
nous sommes si fragile tu me pardonnes
il rit on ne savait pas de bile sa bonne
étoile
je vous l'avais bien dit que nous
ferions son bonheur des échecs en
hauteur en moi la vie est douce pour lui
pas de responsabilité pas de bernissart
pas d'interview et puis j'ai remis mes
col bat je suis très content alors on
dîne ensemble ce soir mais non tout
c'est bien que ce soit c'est le fameux
dîner avec le ministre hajj c'est vrai
c'est pour ce soir devrait inviter par
les ministres maintenant à très bien
choisis ta devise un lift et au début
nous avons rendez vous à 8 heures chez
bayard
quel ennui moi qui aurait tant voulu me
reposer un jour on va vous pourriez pas
m'excuser auprès sont excellents mais
vous n'y pensez pas il a très envie de
vous connaître il a beaucoup entendu
parler moubarki mais par tout le monde
vous êtes une célébrité ma chère il m'a
dit ce n'est pas un dîner officiel à
mener donc votre amie la belle ginevra
fort landi alors vous pensez bien que
dans ce cas c'est bon j'irai la voir
thomas laisse tranquille contrat ça
brille autour de moi tu de reprendre mon
sens je suis juste un petit crochet site
apparaît qu'une autre à bourine tu
devrais aussi enlever ton chapeau que je
serai mieux toi tu as raison apportez
moi un miroir et ben justin le miroir
enfin vous
edouard prend le et donc je me dérange
beaucoup
enfin tu fais toi voyant moissac
mais nous voyons mais le temps comme ça
ça de la femme de chambre
non elle est dans la pièce à côté je
vais l'appeler là mais amélie oui amélie
prenez ce chapeau bien madame le
chauffeur a fait demander à madame pour
qu'ils leur loto ce soit en 8 heures
devant l'hôtel bien madame
et puis monsieur le comte de la
ferronnière a fait téléphoné ce matin
pour savoir s'il pourrait venir voir
madame vers 6h30 et j'ai répondu oui
madame m'habite qu'elle y serait
toujours pour monsieur qu'on fait bien
fait très bien fait ce vieil ami je
serais ravi de le voir
moi aussi j'ai pu faire ranger mes
cheveux dans cette petite glace je vais
dans mon cabinet de toilette je vous
attend ici je ramène aux nouvelles avec
moi vous m'aiderez très bien sûr l'ami
très bien la glace la glace pour ainsi
lui tendant la main
elle y dresser amélie messieurs les
bains un petit coup ça je vous prie non
non non pas celui là
celui-là
pour les pieds non pour mon dos merci eh
ben on peut dire que vous vous en donnez
pas de ma robe tutu le manteau 1
j'ai pris ma retraite et vous n'en avez
pas facile je suis ravie vivre et vous
satisfaite d'être femme de chambre
monsieur si on va trouver la casse qui
me convenait depuis je sais entre au
service de madame ferland dit je ne fais
plus crier et chanter
voyez-vous amélie difficile dans la vie
c'est pas tant d'être heureux que de
savoir mais son bonheur à vous et moi
n'avaient pas compris tout de suite là
on a tâtonné
maintenant nous savons j'étais pas fait
pour être à mort vous étiez pas fait
pour être cocotte vous un ben non alors
parlez plus de ce métier là elle fourbit
quand j'y pense je gêne avec son
extincteur et mon dernier
gonzalez le péruvien ils étaient quatre
au brio leur un type psy chic qui
m'avait promis des choses et à quand
c'est votre photo si vous êtes trop
gagné bon est-ce que je pouvait prévoir
monsieur qui était parti dans ma famille
deux jours à tarbes
j'avais laissé dans mon appartement non
le mien celui de ginette oui enfin le
nôtre enfin je suis revenu plus rien
qu'on allait savez tout déménager j'ai
pu retrouver qu une épingle à cheveux
sur la semaine et du salon je m'en
souviendrai de ce jour là le 16 mars mon
plus grand malheur est mon plus grand
bonheur
le coût de 12 à l'aise et mon entrée à
la fia sacré appartement vient d'arabie
des choses à lui la wii alors vite
dépêchez-vous malabou demande bien
monsieur territoire à signer ça va
savoir un super heureux oui à 13 euros
je ne sais pas tu pourrais être fatigués
avec la victime née ginette bébé lui si
différente de ce qu'elle était si
lointaine cnds a mais j'adore ça mon
vieux vers moi aussi j'ai changé ou
l'ayant je n'aime plus ginette comme
avant pour la bagatelle ou d'ailleurs la
bagatelle qui est ce que tu peux
demander à une femme qui a été en
représentation 14h par je ne sais pas
mais la pauvre petite pense qu'à dormi
elle ne se couche plus elle ton ami mais
quelle satisfaction d'amour propre
chaque sortie est une joie on nous voit
on nous reconnaît tiens y est j'ai une
des plus grandes émotions de ma vie j'ai
pris un tramway au toit par hasard un
bon tu devras sûr et je vois sous une
marque de dentifrice ginevra on la voit
partout rien la boîte trop trop foncée
plus une femme d'une exposition tu sais
tu sais quand on veut pas quand il vaut
mieux que tu as chipata général ont fait
pas à des gentilles passer l'amour
pendant non merci pas savoir je pense
ben mouaïa pêcher ici une maison
charmant j'y passe des soirées délicieux
geipan du tout envie de la voir faire
même assez pour ça et bien rassure toi
mon vieux ginevra ne me quittera jamais
aux essais tu pourquoi c'est parce
qu'elle trouvera jamais mieux que moi
ab ya encore des rois en europe alors
dans ce cas ce serait très flatteur
d'être l'ancien amant d'une presse chrtr
aux propos ont rassuré leur but perdre à
monsieur de la ferronnière demande c'est
peut être reçu mais je pense bien
qu'ayant fait leur entrée pour voir
monsieur le comte de l'affairé 11
ce n'est pas tout à fait bien donc
davantage de belley joazile le pied et
placés les épaules bien vous n'annoncez
pas encore un peu plus le raider dans le
muscle et ce sera parfait
serra mira nous voit et moi nous
monsieur labeaume est votre serviteur je
vous avais pas entendu entre et bonjour
stanislas
notre cher et ravissante habille les
pales elle va venir vous savez bien
gagner toujours pour vous elle m'a fait
la grâce de bloody vous avez quelque
chose de particulier à lui communiquer
je veux lui baissé les ongles et je
partirai compte dans ce cas asseyez
persie et attendez un instant
alors messieurs stanislas on dirait que
vous le sang vous les studios est vous
dire que je gagne beaucoup le temps
depuis que j'ai mon auto elle est très
rapide à vous aimer un bon jour oui j'ai
été bon chez à prix d'or celui du baron
de marange le maroufle emma forte à
droite quand tu avais le son j'ai dû
faire une révolution je lis suffisait
plus les élèves afflux grâce et surtout
à mon succès avec votre belle amie
affront
vous avez dit manuel karam et non je
m'en fous
contout stanislas de la ferronnière
professeur de madame jean evra forland
il a ses bons titres de gloire à moi non
très clair si vous voulez bref je suis
tombé sous le faix j'allais être obligés
d'arrêter quand j'ai eu l'idée d'engager
deux bureaux d'études
le vicomte de maubeuge et le chevalier
la revente à vous recruter en banlieue
mais deux jeunes gens du meilleur monde
que les ennuis momentanée enfin une
compagne bref il me plaît par l'ouvragé
des grossistes les petites leur enseigne
les rudiments et moi je pars et je donne
les indications dernières sont les
tailleurs de marbre je suis le statut
est une offense aux 20 témoins petit
dernier et que voulez vous dire monsieur
et à quoi allez vous dépensez montcourt
est devenu comme un couvent
si l'un d'eux essaie de se permettait le
moindre oubli des convenances il serait
renvoyée aussitôt s'il autorisait les
cales et que deviendrait ma maison je
n'ose dire le mot
eq avec vous monsieur labeaume est
pourquoi les paroles que vous adresser
son côté d'un pays d'amertume que vous
ai je fait c'est souvent le sang qui ont
perverti maginet votre gilet pensez vous
qu'elle était à vous non elle ne vous
appartenez pas plus qu'elle appartient
aujourd'hui à monsieur rincerie des
ginettes dépenses à un homme l état une
file
d'ailleurs si c'est ça qui nous
préoccupe
si vous désirez petit ami vous n'avez
qu'à paris il n'en manque pas
comment vous la faute il pourrait une
nous avons un 10 à 19 ans aux yeux de
biche coup le signer mais nous voulons
d'abord nous avons simone de rungis 21
ans un sourire de titien dont il garde
armé et alors que le pion entre me
demandez-vous
et pourquoi le fait de vous des
reproches je sais oui on sait union des
bons jours la belle entre les bains
la charmeuse entre les chars buzz vous
me flattez vous cherchez à te parler
vous le maître c'est moi aujourd'hui qui
aurait à prendre des leçons à votre
école
vous allez me faire rouge à propos du
col vous connaissez ma dernière recrue
une perte de votre ancienne femme de
chambre elle est venue me trouver il ya
quinze jours elle en est déjà la sixième
le son le tour du lac et le phare avec
la karma l'on vit justement quelle
mémoire est rien et ira assez loin mon
dieu je ne dis pas qu'elle sera invité à
dîner par des ministres à vous savez mon
d'état m'oblige à connaître tous les
petits secrets de la vie parisienne
c'est pour ce soir je sais évidemment la
zone verte de valcourt
c'est son nom a présenté n'ira pas
jusque mais en fait elle apprend avec
beaucoup de facilité
j'attribue cela ce qu'elle vous a frôlé
les a pris en vous voyant d'involontaire
exemple mais j'en suis sûr je voulais
vous demander une permission je
terminais quand je suis arrivé chez vous
de donner une leçon à de jeunes élèves
charmante de débutante j'ai eu l'idée de
les mener dans mon auto et de vous prier
de vous laisser voir à elle un instant
j'ai foncé qui ne pouvait dire au revoir
à ma ne sont depuis éclatant ou une
illustration
elles sont dans l'antichambre qui attend
de votre décision ont soif à rennes sont
payés pour ça mais que voulez-vous
galères rien il suffira qu elle vous
voit parler évoluer sourire quel exemple
pour elle et elle souvenue nos racines
ne va pas permettre ça toi je passe de
poires pourquoi bouillon c'est très
flatteur que vous répondrez d'être
indulgente
elles sont effroyables mon activité
- petit en très vite moselle entrée en
fond puisque l'amf orlandi vous y
autorise madame folle andy a bien voulu
sur mon intercession nous permettre de
la voir un instant ma chère amie
permettez moi de vous présenter
mademoiselle lynette de granville et
mademoiselle jeanne picchu celle ci n'a
pas encore de nom de guerre ah les
petits machins monsieur racine est
monsieur labeaume
oui vous asseoir oh non madame nous
voulons pas vous gêner mais vous
n'imaginez pas maintenant je peux
m'asseoir
alors mademoiselle vous députés ota
vous faites du théâtre oui madame je
joue dans la rue de marigny je fais la
dinde
c'est très bien vous parlez non madame
je suis comme ça c'est comme qui dirait
des ailes n'est ce pas c'est difficile
on a essayé cinq femmes avant d'en
trouver une cuisse et ses voûtes y était
aux bravos et des demoiselles vous
faites aussi des théâtres
non madame je fais rien j'ai fait
contrôler dans une rame de métro
les premières terres quand même mais
c'est nous mais quand on n'a pas de
succès
oui oui beaucoup les médecins peuvent
des messieurs très bien
c'est ça qui m'a donné l'idée tu verrais
ce qui leur a fait dans six mois tient
de qui de la demande et du métro madame
il ya la rechute il voudrait parler à
madame autant soyez gentils montrez vous
regardez jacques bouvard je ne connais
pas ses mots québec il je ne sais pas un
bonhomme pouvoir remarqué avec quelqu'un
c'est la tournée sur toi qui connais pas
seulement 9 des cas litigieux son amant
et tous ses amis des voix sinon tu es
famille bien connue et nous sommes et nc
300000 rageant pour le pavé de paris
connais pas kolda et bien et le mal il
est un peu tard pour que je vous offre
des tasses de thé mais peut-être
prendrez-vous un verre de porto au
madame vous êtes trompés mas blanc veut
pas buzzé mais vous n'avez pas d'amis ou
du porto vient l'homme alors
mesdemoiselles vous voulez vous lui
lancez dans le thème du monde
oui madame le plus difficile dans les
commencements c'est de savoir juger
radom du premier coup d'oeil madame j'ai
l'habitude pour juger les voyageurs qui
monte en première classe avec un billet
de seconde je me trompe et déjà mais pas
tous
excellente apprentissage et dans la vie
c'est un peu plus compliqué reste aussi
forte
regardez là un petit peu pas trop
et encore un petit peu par trop encore
un petit peu
il y en a un peu plus que dans leurs
affaires intérieures
regardez bien comment elle fait merci
madame oui eh bien mes demoiselles de
bouazza votre avenir et reçu le petit
doigt en l'air par sir olé rama chemin
d'affectation non non non chers amis
messieurs jacques babette un
restaurateur qui ouvre à montmartre un
cabaret ultra mandat le porc-épic et il
sollicite l'honneur de vous réserver une
table pour la soirée d'inauguration
qu'il offre au tout paris mardi brochard
je sais vous n'avez que le vendredi est
libre mais monsieur marty est absolument
à vous avoir et il retardera l'ouverture
soit dit sachez monsieur que c'est
d'accord pour un dîner à l'aide reçue
[Applaudissements]
ces petites vous remercie de m gracieuse
à coeur oui madame
au revoir mais mazembe revoir madame
mais elles sont garanties il espère donc
le temps ils feront au point
si d'ici là vous voyez dans vos
relations à monsieur un peu occupé
n'est ce pas qu elles sont mignonnes un
tr min si je vous disais mon cher à pic
il ya quinze jours
la demoiselle du tertre ne pouvait pas
prononcer de phrases sans dire mince et
je garde quand à la demoiselle du métro
elle se curer les ongles avec des
boutiques et ça fera souffrir les hommes
et ils en seront tanche à il faut que je
file chers amis je passerai comprendre
vers 7h40 bien c'est fait voir ce que tu
ferais si j'étais gentil mais je suis ok
vous irez chez un fleuriste tu vas chez
très de rose thé très pâle s'avérer très
bien avec ma robe est interdit à tout à
l'heure je vais avoir ma petite gêne
êtes vous venu et non jaurès encore
amant contrat liant ainsi va chers amis
c'est vrai vous dînez avait été ministre
quel triomphe pour ma méthode avez vous
étudié la note que je vous ai envoyé oui
je suis en mesure de dire une phrase sur
les retraites ouvrières une sur l'impôt
sur le revenu et une sur le privilège
des bouilleurs de cru inutile de vous le
faire répéter je suis sûr qu'avec vous
ce sera bien sûr et bien dit la place et
les adroitement mais n'insistez pas cet
homme n'est pas un saut comme on
pourrait le croire
il est au contraire forte intelligente
une situation énorme une fortune
colossale socialiste
treize amateurs de jolies femmes quoique
n'ayant pas de liaison sérieuse mais
qu'avez vous vous m'écoutez à peine
stanislav ne palestine et avec quoi
qu'est ce que vous dites je dis je de
paris j'ai entendu enfin vous êtes un
sens et ce deal est là pour vous une
importance considérable
c'est justement pour cela que j'y vais
je sais ce qui m'attend je devine enfin
voilà deux mois qui tracasse costa pour
me connaître et l'autre jour en riant
elle a même chiper une de mes photos et
bien d'un moment j'en ai assez stanislas
je ne vais plus montés trop tard vous
êtes une force qui va vous ne pouvez
plus vous arrêter
non quelque chose est en vous qui vous
dit marc stanislas j'étais très content
entre faut un ballon à loi dont tu rêves
d'enfantillages je vois ce que c'est les
vapeurs un peu de neurasthénie non pas
sérieux vous irez à ce dîner mais pelé
réseau ministre et il arrivera ce qui
est écrit au livre du destin stanislas
je suis une petite femme simple vous
êtes une des reines de paris
depuis quand une reine abdique tel soit
j'irai mal et vous en stanislas vous
êtes un méchant je m'en vais
je ma chère amie
je suis très content de moins est assez
content d'eux
[Applaudissements]
madame puisque madame d'asile est en
ville est ce que je pourrais avoir ma
soirée une certainement si même je
pouvais montrer que demain matin
j'allais faire la bombe jouit la dame de
détente et amis d'amis d'amis oui ma
dame appelle pas madame on est tout seul
thème petit ami jeune 25 ans alors c'est
quoi pourtant m aux affaires ou banon
alors j'en ai soupé des affaires c'est
du sérieux
le mariage non il est gentil tout plein
il est même bien tu étais que j'étais
femme de chambre depuis toujours il
croit qu'il est le second rage je n'ai
et je fabriquais matinée avec louis
tobback des cagoules honte et qui sera
partie vous amuserez vient tous les deux
probables
on a eu de la veine à l'eva ma fille va
dîner avec ton petit vendeur il revient
de mahler que dira merci
ces gentilles
[Applaudissements]
madame c'est un monsieur qui peut rêver
à madame corps absolument impossible
aussi fait entrer
on
revers quelle surprise quelle heureuse
surprise
essayez-vous merci permettez-moi d'abord
de vous féliciter
voilà devenu une personne s'élève je
vous en prie n'essayez pas ironie mais
je ne le suis pas je vous assure
j'aurais préféré que vous vous moquez un
petit peu de moi pourquoi c'est
difficile à expliquer je suis venu vous
annoncer une nouvelle une grande
nouvelle de vie n'est pas non je me
marie avec la fille de monsieur poulard
chez qui j'étais secrétaire et dont je
deviens associés j'ai beaucoup travaillé
je suis devenu l'homme indispensable et
j'ai fini par vivre constamment près de
lui et près de sa fille nous sommes plus
et hier son père a consenti c'est vous
qui m'avez fait rentrer dans cette
maison et c'est à vous que je dois à mon
bonheur c'est pourquoi j'ai voulu vous
annoncer la nouvelle à vous la première
la première premier oui oui personne ne
le sait que c'est gentil je suis très
touché de cette attention elle ne
m'étonne pas de votre part phase i dont
vous vous mariez assez drôle je ne veux
pas me figurer moi qui vous ai connu six
indépendance bohème et oui moi aussi
j'ai changé et c'est à vous que je le
dois
mais oui rappelez vous c'est vous qui
m'avez dit il faut un jour ou l'autre se
ranger songer à son avenir et vous aviez
raison avec six raisons que cela
c'est surprenant que vous avez changé
vous aussi autrefois vous aviez l'air
pardonnez moi de dire cela mais vous
aviez l'air de poser de jouer à la dame
est maintenant cela vous est naturelle
naturelle
il ya encore bien du chiqué vous êtes
franche avec vous avec vous seulement
mais il faut pas le répéter mais de vous
à moi la vraie femme que je suis ce
n'est pas une oeuvre
ce n'est même pas geneviève c'est
ginette la petite femme de la refonte et
ça m'a tout remué
voir le passé le passé je voudrais vous
poser une question mais peut-être est un
discret non non on dit
vous aimez votre fiancée bien sûr enfin
je veux dire vous l'aimez d'amour oui
profondément à et allez vous m
oui elle s'est fait ridicule ce que je
vais vous dire mais elle enfin ne nous
adorons est bien vrai les a très très
heureux très heureux oui et grâce à vous
eh bien mon cher robert je suis très
contente pour vous sincèrement faudra
bien qu'on te dise la nouvelle serre ils
se marieront avec la fille de monsieur
poulat c'est très bien ça jeunes ont
vaincu je m'en doutais un petit peu mais
comme levier jamais rien dit oui mais je
voulais d'abord annoncé la nouvelle à
ginette vous fait des compliments à mon
ami plein mais bien entendu tiens
d'ailleurs je donne ce soir avec lui
avec sa fille
on me dit non j'ai bien envie de
m'inviter justement ce soir je ne dîne
avec un ministre les veuves et nous
allons dîner dans un petit restaurant de
montmartre les chats bottés la châtre et
et je m'en souviens avec son patron
eugène qui goûtent à l'essence avant de
les servir c'est ça oui qu'elle s'était
gay alors ce soit en vitesse est attendu
comme vous allez vous amuser à voir
ginette nous verrons probablement pas
vous comprenez je comprends on ne
s'embrasse pas
adieu robert
adieu robin citron il me semble que je
me dis à dire elle m'a dit qu'est ce que
tu as toi
ouais regarde moi et bakar mois étupes
le minot tu voudrais pas simplement une
petite bulle elle un bon robert se marie
c'est du passé qui finit au quai à toi
je peux bien te le dire tu es un vieil
ami tu vois robert je crois bien que je
lis un peu aimé aussi bien naturel et
c'est pour ça que tu peux non pas
seulement mais tu vois j'ai comme une
idée que plus jamais je pourrais et
mettez de façon là alors tu comprends ça
fait quelque chose
mais oui je comprend ce qu'on prouve des
gentils et doit aller pleurs mon petit
pleut mais non je ne peux pas ça me
démaquille diraient les tempes madame
sabine pour le dîner a oui c'est vrai je
te laisse rôle on ne va pas en fait je
vais dire pas tout à fait jurer que tu
sois là tout à l'heure quand je partirai
j'ai tellement besoin d'un ami on mais
je serai là haut je sais là haut puis tu
sais tu que je te dit tout à l'heure
c'était pas très sérieux voudra le
répétez à personne on se moquerait deux
mois du promer jamais on met jamais
mopti au jamais jamais
[Applaudissements]
c'était sa robe beige que madame mais
pour le dîner oui la belle est là avec
la parure de rugby mais avec les rubis
home is a tramp est à la fin de ce mois
ci pour un soir je dois d'être comme
distraire amélie qu'est ce que tu dirais
si j'allais dealé avec vous deux un mois
était faletau me dis que j'en ai soupé
du ministre des retraites ouvrières avec
pudeur de crue des foires amélie
laisse-moi la dépouille soit tranquille
je serai discrète et après le dîner il
disparaîtrait et même si vous voulez
vous des côtés pendant que je serai
là-bas foulera pas vous gêner moi tu
vois dans ces petits caboulot il me
semble que je serai là ginette
d'autrefois d'il ya un an
il ya longtemps prodi amélie tu veux
bien mais tu es pense pas pierre dinon
sera complètement affolé quand il verra
si fier avec ta robe de sens l'ouïe et
tout et cailloux mais non je remettrai
ma petite robe d'autres lagarde est pas
bien sûr je la sors parfois ça me
rappelle le bon temps et je vais la
mettre à ce soir au que ce sera bon le
dit amélie tu veux bien humain lui rit
pas sûr que je peux bien tu es gentil
jeu comme à liège et aider et nous on
reste ici tout empêchera les gens
d'entrer dans ma chambre
et si quelqu'un vienne il retiendra ici
et nous nous filerons par l'escalier de
service
eh ben on voit là une histoire
on reçoit on me reçoit toujours oui
merci mais à cette heure ci est bien
disparaissez amélie vous avez votre
maîtresse et sa bile pour le vivez kfir
sans vous oui monsieur dans sa chambre
et vecteurs et bien visé n'était pas
visible en bas pour petit
si vous acceptez quelque chose mais bien
c'est pas facile et bien très bien très
bien je l'attendrai ici car je me méfie
ginette m'a dit tout à l'heure des
choses qui m'ont pas qu'ils étaient les
femmes je les connais elles sont
capables des pires sottise
st je veux la voir partir la voir de mes
propres yeux bien monsieur je vais aider
madame ans pour rester si c'est la cas
de mademoiselle veut s'habiller seul
voulais me le dit pas rester ici ne
répondait pas je vous défaut de réponse
à mes limites je me demande qu'est ce
que vous venez faire ici - l'équipage
est signée vous d'aller où je ne sais
pas où non non vous alliez vous galvaudé
vous vous alliez gaspiller le trésor que
vous êtes soilih démence par bonheur je
veillais sinon comment ginebra vous
n'êtes pas encore prêtes pour signifie
ce monsieur meyer un malentendu ça nous
sommes déjà très en retard et le
ministre qui attend elle sera prête dans
saint denis soit dû les mettre en avant
mes amis je vous suis au nom de domaine
alors ici ici oui non le salon habillez
vous ici devant moi à les charger la
rend ma pauvre amélie c'est râpé ça n'en
a l'air
vous allez chercher des bijoux mais
qu'est ce que c'est tout ce poids là non
moi je vous garde vous allez chercher le
manteau
qu'elle vous est cruel oui mais si vous
croyez moi que je pense en ce moment
vous vous trompez moi j'ai fini je suis
arrivé vous pas encore bien sûr je vous
comprends ça vous pèse de vendre ou
grimace ma pauvre enfant nous en sommes
tous là moi aussi je mens les miennes et
ça n'est pas toujours très drôle et nous
avons bien le droit vous comme moi
d'avoir nos moments de découragement et
d'émotion il ne faut pas s'y attarder
évident ils penseront plus peut-être
mais j'arrête eux-mêmes voulait un peu
de bonheur du bonheur là vous en
demander trop il faut bien laisser
quelque chose à celles qui ne
réussissent pas
vite vite nous sommes très en retard
mais que dire à 2 min qui calmez-vous
mon ami c'est moi qui l'exposerait en
pleine nuit le collier
[Musique]
à cela
avancez vous un peu
la cape
voilà tu es parfait
il
tu mon dieu mais que direz-vous ministre
eh bien j'ai bourran stanislas une
phrase je pris votre excellent jeu pris
votre excellence de vouloir bien me
pardonner de vouloir bien me pardonner
le retard involontaire le retard
involontaire
[Applaudissements]
la pièce que nous avons eu la joie de
jouer pour vous ce soir et de messieurs
aaron est géré bidon
dans des décors de roger arc
des costumes de donald cardwell
une mise en scène de jacques hardoin
avec bertrand lepage
lisbeth arnaud
le feb rebelles
[Applaudissements]
marie ces honneurs
marie-odile green vague
bernard typhaine
jacques hardoin
[Applaudissements]
laurence et blu
chaque dinar
daniel devins
et jean-jacques
et amaro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]